[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous bienvenue sur
public sénat dans une demi heure vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct la
conférence de presse de gérard larcher
le président du sénat présente ce matin
les 50 propositions du sénat pour un
nouvel acte de décentralisation pour le
plein exercice des libertés locales on
va tout analyser tout décortiqué avec
trois spécialistes sur ce plateau
géraldine chabrier bonjour en juin merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes avocate vous
êtes professeur de droit public à
l'université paris 1 panthéon sorbonne
est spécialisé dans la décentralisation
et les collectivités locales également
sur ce plateau benjamin morel jour
bonjour vous êtes politologue maître de
conférences à l'université paris ii
panthéon sorbonne et les plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau jean
baptiste forêt bonjour rédacteur en chef
délégué de la gazette des communes et en
duplex depuis la présidence du sénat où
va se dérouler toute cette conférence de
presse notre journaliste alexandre plus
tard bonjour alexandre cette conférence
de presse ce rapport ce sont les
réponses du sénat au président de la
république à emmanuel macron qui
souhaite une nouvelle dynamique
territoriale c'est en tout cas ce qu'il
a dit le 14 juin lors de l'une de ces
allocutions ont effectivement tam dans
un discours où le président la
république tirait les leçons de la crise
sanitaire et il avait reconnu que
l'organisation de l'état était trop
centralisée depuis paris on les quotas
plus je lis marquer
tout ne peut pas être décidé si souvent
à paris face à l'épidémie
les citoyens les entreprises les
syndicats les associations les
collectivités locales les agents de
l'état dans les territoires ont su faire
preuve d'ingéniosité d'efficacité de
solidarité faisons-leur davantage
confiance
libérons la créativité et l'énergie du
terrain emmanuel macron veut donc ouvrir
une nouvelle page de son quinquennat où
il donne plus de pouvoir à ces acteurs
de terrain aux hôpitaux aux entreprises
aux universités également au maire un
nouvel acte de décentralisation même si
il n'a pas prononcé le mot de
décentralisation pendant son discours
est en réalité le gouvernement travaille
à déjà sur une réforme territoriale
annoncée à la fin de la crise des gilet
jaune avec la fameuse loi 3d pour
décentralisation différenciation à des
concentrations et les propositions qui
vont être présentés ce matin par le
président du sénat elles sont basées sur
un travail mené depuis des mois par un
groupe trans partisan ici au sénat
notamment pour relayer la fronde des
collectivités depuis trois ans qui
dénonce une perte d'autonomie de pouvoir
face à l'état central parisien
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes ces
explications vous retrouve tout au long
de cette émission avec vos invités r
jean baptiste forêt alexandre l'a
rappelé et d'un emmanuel macron le 14
juin a dit tout ne peut pas être
décidées depuis paris libérons la
créativité du terrain mais il a dit
aussi la pas pour autant parler de
décentralisation qu'est-ce que ça
annonce pour vous dans l'esprit du
président de la république
dans l'esprit du président de la
république on est quand même dans une
phase de post qu'ovide 19,1 post crise
majeure c'est pas ce qu'il va advenir
hélas dans les prochaines les prochaines
semaines et même macron reconnaît quand
même de cette façon là que l'état a
failli quand même dans cette dans cette
crise on a vu quand même une
organisation assez technocratique se
mettre en mouvement extrêmement
lentement je songe en particulier aux
agences régionales de santé on a eu
aussi un train d'ordonnancé interminable
onu un protocole sanitaire dans les
écoles de 63 pages
ça a été un peu la caricature de ce
qu'il ne fallait pas faire quand même
cette gestion de crise benjamin morel
vous êtes d'accord avec l'analyse de
jean baptiste forrest a montré
toutes les insuffisances de l'état est
au contraire et bien peut-être l'intérêt
des collectivités dans ce contexte alors
est ce que ça montre et l'agilité des
collectivités très certainement ou en
tout cas ça a montré notamment l'agilité
des communes et ça a également montré
bien parfois lentilles heureusement de
l'état déconcentré avec en effet et bien
une perspective un peu trop concentrés
de cet état là donc dans le discours d'
emmanuel macron si vous lisez un peu
entre les lignes il ya certes de la
décentralisation mais il ya également
beaucoup et c'était une intuition qui
venait de louvain savait déjà été
développés au monde et j'ai des jeunes
l'idée de déconcentrer notamment de rené
de redonner du pouvoir aux préfets et de
des agents s'y fier l'état après sur les
collectivités territoriales ce qui est
intéressant quand on écoute le discours
d' emmanuel macron ya quelques semaines
c'est qu'il cite les maires il ne cite
pas les départements il ne cite pas les
régions donc on voit très clairement que
cet acte de décentralisation s'il a lieu
il est loin d'être évident pour
l'instant président en hausse
aujourd'hui se dit départementaliste on
voit qu'il tend à jouer les conseils
départementaux contre les conseils
régionaux on a des rumeurs de report des
élections départementales et régionales
un des rumeurs de retour du conseil
territorial
donc ça pour l'un du conseiller
territorial donc pour ça tous les ans
pour tout ça pour l'instant reste
visiblement assez peu clair dans la tête
du président de la république
ce qui est certain est bien c'est qu'il
ya une volonté de défaire un petit peu
ce qui fait territoire unis donc l'union
des grandes et les grandes associations
d'élus locaux avec la présence de gérard
larcher
justement pour tenter de jouer les
niveaux de collectivités les uns contre
les autres
géraldine savary il faut dire que depuis
le début de ce quinquennat les relations
de l'exécutif avec les collectivités
elles sont compliquées elles le sont en
effet les relations avec l'état était
compliquée avant l'arrivée de manuel
macron elles se sont
tendu davantage avec la loi notre île
est une politique de la chaise vide
c'est bien un conseil national dès
territoires où je me souviens lors du
congrès des départements où les
présidents de conseils départementaux
ont quitté la salle lorsque la ministre
a voulu faire son discours
et puis on a quand même eu en cours de
mandat un revirement d'attitude puisque
les gilets jaunes ont été un nouveau
moment de tension et emmanuel macron
s'est rendu compte le président s'est
rendu compte que finalement les maires
avait bien senti ce qui se produisait
sur le territoire a bien pris la mesure
de la crise étaient les plus proches à
commencer à les inviter vous souvenez à
l'elysée et depuis on est quand même
plutôt sur une phase de décontraction
des relations et il faut se souvenir que
ce dont on va parler dans un instant a
été entamée bien avant l'épidémie on
était sur le projet doit 3d ce cette
nouvelle ère de la décentralisation
qu'on veut créer n'est que la
perpétuation de ce qui était fait avant
avec le risque néanmoins que la pandémie
effectivement créé des tensions entre
collectivités et que le président macron
s'engouffrent dans cette dans cette
possibilité jean baptiste forêt pourtant
on se rappelle que dans un premier temps
l'exécutif avait mis en place la
conférence nationale des territoires il
avait dit et bien vouloir oeuvrer contre
et bien à la fracturation territoriales
oui mais il ya quand même un hic depuis
le début c'est dire qu emmanuel macron
est quand même le premier président de
la république depuis georges pompidou
enfin georges pompidou était conseiller
municipal mais avec très peu d'actions
locales c'est le premier président de la
république à ne pas avoir d'expérience
territoriale donc d'entrée ça a suscité
quand même un certain nombre de tirages
avec les représentants des associations
d'élus c'est un phénomène qui était
amplifiée par la fin du cumul du cumul
des mandats et qui aujourd'hui est
encore renforcé par ce qui s'est passé
aux municipales c'est dire qu'on a des
forces politiques locales très puissante
le parti socialiste et les républicains
à côté et de l'autre des forces
politiques nationales qui ont du mal à
s'enraciner en particulier la république
la république en marche donc on ne
réussit pas à faire dialoguer c'est de
ces deux scènes là comme en allemagne en
allemagne à des structures qui
fonctionnent très bien de ce point de
vue là là il ya toujours de la friture
sur la ligne la fameuse conférence
nationale des territoires s'est pas
réuni depuis
plus de deux ans à ma connaissance il
n'y a pas de lui alors ça devait leur
rendez vous prévu miel ça devait être un
rendez vous régulier et puis ça été
complètement annoncé m'accroche pas du
tout
vous êtes d'accord dont j'ai un moral
sur ce que révèle aussi bien les
élections municipales elle montrée bien
cette fracturation du paysage politique
oui très clairement vous avez une
recomposition politique dont il va
falloir voir si elle perdure mais en
tout cas qui existent au niveau national
prenez les dernières enquêtes d'opinion
pour ce qu'elles valent quelques années
avant la présidentielle
mais en tout cas vous voyez que vous
avez quand même aujourd'hui deux grands
pôles un pôle la république en marche
qui tient dans les enquêtes au niveau
national et de l'autre un paul
rassemblement national qui a tort ou à
raison pour l'instant structure le la
bipolarité de la vie politique française
au niveau local on a vu qu'il n'en était
rien on retrouve une bipolarité droite
gauche on retrouve et bien un
fonctionnement des appareils politiques
qui est ma foi assez classique donc en
effet il ya de la friture sur la ligne
et il ya une opposition qui n'est plus
seulement une opposition entre
formations politiques mais qui est une
opposition également horizontale entre
les collectivités territoriales tenu par
parti socialiste la gauche plus
largement et les républicains et de
l'autre
l'assemblée nationale les grandes
structures nationales par ailleurs et
bien du coup ça crée des difficultés
dans le dialogue mais ça crée évidemment
également des difficultés dans la
conception c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas
qu emmanuel macron qui n'a pas été élu
local dans ce gouvernement
si vous enlevez jean yves le drian dans
une bien moindre mesure richard ferrand
président de l'assemblée nationale mais
qui n'était que conseiller régional
vous voyez que les anciens élus locaux
dans ce gouvernement sont peau de
chagrin et donc du coup ne représente
pas réellement j'enlève jacqueline
gourault également n'enlève et sébastien
lecornu mais bon là qui sont spécialisés
dans la question n'avait pas justement
c'est peut-être vous n'avez peut-être
vous n'avez pas justement cette ce
souffle territoriales mais également les
intérêts qu'il ya derrière
et du coup la capacité de la base de
faire pression sur le haut autant vous
l'avez dire il ya par exemple jacqueline
gourault ancienne sénatrice qui a
travaillé et bien sûr cette loi 3d à
laquelle vous faisait référence
décentralisation différenciation des
concentrations ça devait être une des
grandes lois de décentralisation de
cette année quel était son état d'esprit
géraldine chabrier
écoutez il faut souligner que c'est une
ministre qui est une femme de terrain
d'abord qui connaît très très bien les
collectivités territoriales qui a
conservé de bonnes relations avec pas
mal d'élus elle était dans une
perspective la dernière fois que j'ai pu
en discuter avec elle de collaboration
c'est à dire que l'idée c'était
effectivement le projet de loi 3d devait
être remplie en collaboration avec les
collectivités territoriales avec les
associations d'élus avec les chambres le
la différenciation et est un thème qui
lui remontaient énormément qui étaient
remontées du terrain et qu'il
intéressait particulièrement je crois
qu'elle était vraiment sur cet équilibre
3d décentralisation déconcentration et
expérimentations avec la difficulté qui
est toujours là même qui est qu'il ya
beaucoup d'attentes des collectivités
territoriales mais parfois beaucoup de
difficultés à formuler les les besoins
et les réponses législatives à ces
questions d'où ce travail collaboratif
et je trouve que le la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes réunis ici n'est
que l'aboutissement en effet de cette
démarche collaborative de la ministre
qui est membre d'un gouvernement
collégial mais qui entend aussi très
bien la base allez on va rejoindre tout
de suite alexandre plus sarah la
présidence du sénat alexandre vous êtes
avec un thierry dupont journalistes à
contexte et il a d'ailleurs dévoilé un
certain nombre d'éléments qui concerne
et bien c'est 50 propositions du sénat
effectivement tam tiré du pont avec
votre site contexte vous avait dévoilé
les les pistes de ceux des propositions
que gérard larcher va présenter ce matin
en général il veut donner plus de
pouvoir aux collectivités et plus de
compétences il y à il ya un dialogue
entre entre le chef de l'état ni le
maquereau et les collectivités locales
savoir est-ce qu'il faut décentraliser
plus c'est ce qu'il faut leur donner
plus de compétences dans ce dialogue
gérard larcher s'est invitée à la fois
la demande des collectivités locales
puisqu'elles avaient demandé elle avait
commencé à travailler gérard larcher dès
le mois de janvier sur le sujet de la
loi 3d pour une essayé d'écrire ensemble
une
une contribution à l'élaboration de la
3d et puis récemment emmanuel macron lui
a demandé au président du sénat mais
également de l'assemblée nationale et du
conseil économique social et
environnemental de l'aider de lui faire
part de leurs idées pour la relance pour
la prêt pour l'après crise et gérard
larcher lui a visiblement décidé de
s'emparer du thème de décentralisation
et de faire de faire porter sa réponse
sur ce thème de la décentralisation
alors il pourrait prendre du coup à la
balle au bond oui avec cette demande de
contribution des manuels macron est ce
que le président du sénat va également
modifier sa copie en tirant les leçons
de la crise sanitaire notamment sur le
pouvoir des régions en matière de santé
alors oui dans l'est dans les
propositions que nous avons pu consulter
on voit très bien quand on tire les
leçons de la crise notamment sur
l'organisation de l'état territorial
c'est à dire des services déconcentrés
de l'état
on sent bien qu'il ya une volonté de
renforcer le pouvoir des préfets de
département c'est un constat quasi
unanimes il faut redonner du pouvoir
il faut incarner le pouvoir de l'état
par un homme et cet homme ça doit être
le préfet qui auraient en temps de crise
par exemple vocation à diriger toutes
les tous les services de l'état on sait
que par exemple les ars agences
régionales de santé échapper aux
pouvoirs des préfets les informations
remontait en silo mais il n'y avait
absolument pas localement de partage de
l'information et donc et puis renforcé
également le couple préfet maire qui a
très bien fonctionné donne notamment
durant de déconfinement très bien donc
le couple préfet maire qui devrait
sortir un gagnant de des leçons tirer de
cette crise sanitaire
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
interview alors voilà pour à l'aperçu
donné par thierry dupont de ces 50
propositions pour le plein exercice des
libertés locales 1 le ton est donné
qu'elles sont les grandes lignes que
nous avons retenue nous de ce rapport au
très vite à ce vous en donne un avant
goût
regardez les 50 propositions seront
présentées par gérard larcher mais tous
les groupes politiques du sénat ont
participé à la réflexion une abstention
bienveillante de la droite et du centre
nous a permis de faire passer notre
proposition de résolution tous veulent
plus de liberté pour les collectivités
locales parmi les grands thèmes des
sujets demandée depuis longtemps par
plusieurs associations d'élus des sujets
qui ont même figure
dans des projets de loi comme
l'inscription du droit à la
différenciation locales dans la
constitution
en clair adapté l'action publique
l'aménagement du territoire par exemple
aux spécificités locales en trouvant la
juste mesure pour ne pas tomber dans le
fédéralisme gérard larcher l'évoquait
déjà lors de ses voeux en janvier
la différenciation dès lors que les
défilés organisés ne remet pas en cause
le principe d'égalité
au contraire elle peut même constituer
un moyen de garantir l'égalité notamment
l'égalité des chances qui aujourd'hui on
le sait bien
n'est pas vraiment assuré autre thème
l'argent pour le sénat l'autonomie
financière des collectivités doit être
garanti un moratoire sur la réforme
actuelle des finances locales pourraient
être demandées la chambre haute pourrait
aussi s'appuyer sur la gestion de crise
du coc vite 19 pour demander
l'attribution de nouvelles compétences
aux départements et aux régions
les présidents de région pourrait ainsi
prendre la tête des ars avec ses
propositions les sénateurs disent
vouloir restaurer l'unité nationale et
réaffirmer le rôle des élus locaux
comprendre la reconstruction du pays
entreprise par emmanuel macron ne se
fera pas sans eux
géraldine chavrier plus de libertés
locales
avec ce rapport on se retrouve
finalement face à certains credo du
sénat ce sont des on a déjà entendu ces
paroles là de la part du sénat
absolument et il est très dans la
continuité de ce qu'il a toujours dit il
ya déjà plusieurs mois maintenant qu'ils
se prononcent en faveur de la
différenciation et quand on regarde ce
qui s'est produit pendant les épidémies
on se rend compte à quel point c'est
important l'état a traité la l'ensemble
du territoire comme s'ils étaient
touchés de façon équivalente sur chacune
de ces parties du territoire si on avait
déjà fait de la différenciation aurait
déjà donné un petit peu plus de
souplesse y compris en terme de
conséquences économiques
le tenue financière le cadre une
préoccupation de longue aussi 1,2 du
sénat qui quels représentants des
collectivités territoriales et la
nécessité de faire avancer la révision
constitutionnelle dans son volet
décentralisation le scénar est
évidemment moins favorable à d'autres
mesures de la révision constitutionnelle
est
et beaucoup plus sur toutes les
questions de 2000 financière
différenciation expérimentation qui qui
qui devait être dans la constitution et
je regrette que les questions annexes ne
nous est pas permis d'avancer plus vite
sur les questions de décentralisation
une révision constitutionnelle qui se
fait plus que jamais attendre benjamin
morel votre réaction oui elle est assez
improbable avion conçu une aile à ce
stade là il faut pas oublier qu'à partir
de septembre on a quinze mois d'agenda
parlementaire effectif avant le début de
la campagne et que la droite n'a pas
réellement intérêt de faire cadeau à
emmanuel macron d'un référendum ou d'un
congrès quelques mois avant la
présidentielle
donc il ya des raisons politiques qui
font qu'ils font que c'est compliqué il
me semble y avoir deux points
consensuels c'est d'un côté la
déconcentration avec notamment le
renforcement du couple maire préfet de
l'autre un renforcement potentiel des
conseils généraux et même des rumeurs de
retour de la clause de compétence
générale pour les départements
ce serait en effet une façon de remettre
le département au centre et des le grand
débat en réalité on voyait qu emmanuel
macron dont s'était pas vraiment la
culture politique tourner un peu
départementaliste met donc là il ya des
points qui peuvent probablement conduire
à une forme de consensus
ensuite la question de la
différenciation elle est polysémique en
réellement c'est devenu c'est devenu
aujourd'hui un peu un mot valise quand
vous écoutez richard ferrand il
semblerait que ce soit une addition de
collectivités à statut particulier avec
comme modèle l'alsace et la corse
quand vous attendez gérard larcher s'est
pas tout à fait ça qui dit il dit
notamment refusé
il avait dit ça au moment du congrès des
maires qu'il y ait des exceptions et que
la différenciation puisse être normative
puisse être dans les compétences oui
mais pas dans une forme de france à la
carte donc là on voit qu'il ya très
clairement des clivages très très fort
il ya un deuxième point qui n'est pas
forcément également consensuelle c'est
la question d'autonomie fiscale
et là très clairement on voit qu
emmanuel macron n'a probablement pas
intérêts en tout cas pas envie de
revenir sur la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation
pourtant pour les collectivités
territoriales la liberté c'est pas
seulement de savoir quoi faire de en
termes de dépenses c'est également
d'avoir un levier une forme de contrôle
sur leurs recettes et ça pour l'instant
ça bloque
oui le principe qui décident psa est un
principe que l'on connaît bien défendue
par françois baroin et l'association des
maires de france et c'est la réponse
bien sûr à la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation qui a suscité la grogne des
territoires
oui bien sûr on va les élus locaux jeu
depuis cherché à pousser leur avantage
on voit les associations d'élus réclamé
une suspension de la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation sait déjà que les fameux
contrats de maîtrise de la dépense
locale contre hadid de cahors ont été
ont été gelée mais on est quand même
dans une situation financière
je vous fais pas un dessin c'est assez
complexe l'état déjà mis la main à la
poche à hauteur de quatre milliards et
demi
philippe laurent et le numéro 3 de
l'association des maires de france dit
il manque 20 milliards
je suis pas certain que l'état ira ira
jusque là mais c'est difficile c'est ces
discussions toujours achopper
effectivement sur le nerf de la guerre
les finances locales
oui le nerf de la guerre ce sont les
finances locales et et cette réforme de
la taxe d'habitation qui a mis le feu
aux poudres
ah la la réforme de la taxe d'habitation
a mis le feu aux poudres mais il ya très
longtemps que la mèche était allumé avec
des situations qui sont un peu aberrante
en france en matière de financement
c'est que lors du budget du vote du
budget de l'état les collectivités
territoriales ont les pires difficultés
avant les informations dont elles ont
besoin pour agir puisque toutes les
informations relatives au financement
des collectivités territoriales aux
dépenses contraintes etc sont
complètement éclatés
on a un principe d'autonomie financière
qui est constitutionnel qui ne sert à
rien donc il va falloir être très malin
dans l'est dans les mois qui viennent
parce que puisque vous avez entièrement
raison le temps n'est plus à la révision
constitutionnelle il faudra jouer que
les lois organiques il faut modifier de
loi organique pour pouvoir redonner une
capacité une plus grande autonomie
financière aux collectivités
territoriales et de la même façon la loi
organique pour pouvoir voir une
expérimentation qui deviennent une
différenciation sans révision
constitutionnelle mais la révision
constitutionnelle a va être très
compliqué et pourtant bien écouter le
président du groupe l air au sénat il
était l'invité de notre émission
audition publique lundi et là encore eh
bien il a dit qu'il allait la réclame
est écrite et bruno retailleau et la
démocratie on doit la reconstruire par
le haut et par le bas
le bas c'est parce que la notion
proximité je dis souvent le lieu c'est
le lien c'est parce que c'est dans la
proximité qu'on tisse des liens les uns
avec les autres parce qu'on se connaît
si j'ose dire de visage à visage de
regard hagard donc il ya cette question
de la démocratie c'est aussi dans la
proximité qu'on établit +22 d'efficacité
et on l'a vu on a un état bureaucratique
qui a montré ses
insuffisance au moment de la gestion de
la crise sanitaire donc je crois que on
doit ouvrir si j'ose dire les choses les
perspectives pour les collectivités
donner plus de liberté ne pas avoir peur
des expérimentations de la
différenciation déconcentré l'état au
niveau départemental il va falloir
engager une vraie étape de la
décentralisation
mais vous savez ça n'est pas que des
lois c'est une pratique parce que toute
l'histoire de la décentralisation en
france c'est une histoire où l'état
d'abord à cordes d'une main et puis il
reprend de l'autre main donc il faudra
qu'on trouve des clics et pour faire en
sorte que on arrive y compris dans la
constitution à avoir oui absolument et
on va tout de suite rejoindre alexandre
poussard alexandre vous êtes avec jean
marie bockel le président de la
délégation aux collectivités et
co-rapporteur est bien de ce rapport
effectivement jean marie bockel vous
avez mené les travaux de ce groupe trans
partisan au sénat qui a contribué à la
future loi de décentralisation
comment se sont passées ces travaux il
ya eu un consensus entre tous les
groupes au sénat un très bon état
d'esprit
un consensus sur la méthode c'est à dire
que dans le document qui sera remis en
même temps que la présentation de ce
matin vous verrez les contributions des
différents groupes politiques avec leurs
nuances pour sensibilité mais une
adhésion sur l'essentiel et un accord
avec la méthode de travail cinq mois de
travail approfondie et une application
personnel du président larcher à chaque
étape de travaux y compris pendant le
confinement et avec philippe bas prix
selon la commission des lois et moi-même
au titre de la délégation aux
collectivités une très bonne entente
bien sûr une une complémentarité nos
collègues
moi je peux parler pour la délégation
j'ai souvent on a fait un travail
fournisseurs c'est à dire que on a
organisé chemin faisant des tables
rondes et auditions au service de cette
démarche commune du groupe de travail
des couteaux 6 1
monde des élus des associations donc
franchement un très bon esprit et très
studieux très constructif et très au
fond des choses
est ce qu'il ya un consensus ici au
sénat sur le bilan des manuels macron
depuis trois ans qui a plutôt quand même
recentrer le pouvoir à paris et fait
perdre un peu d'autonomie aux
collectivités le constat est partagé de
la situation actuelle je veux dire
l'actuel président évidemment est
concerné mais pas que lui enfin on a
aussi eu avant dé loi bavarde qui vont
pas forcément clarifier le paysage
on a été confronté à des réduction des
dotations aux territoires ça c'était
avant
ensuite il ya eu au début de l'actuel
quinquennat bain par exemple la
contractualisation à la manière de
cahors 1 qui était une grande rencontre
qui devait renforcer l'esprit de
contractualisation et qui a été de ce
point de vue là un échec
le président lui même a reconnu donc
effectivement on est sur un une toile de
fond un qui est aujourd'hui plus qu en
demi teinte 1 est-ce que vous pensez que
le président m'a qu'on peut sortir de
son costume de jupiter est donnée
libérer les énergies comme il dit des
acteurs de terrain et des territoires
franchement c'est une bonne question
jusqu'à présent c'est pas vraiment
arriver un par delà ce qui a pu être dit
mais
au fond
on a tous l'espoir que là nous serons
enfin entendu vraiment car la démarche
est constructive mais de toute façon ce
que ce que nous allons dire aujourd'hui
des 50 propositions avec gérard larcher
nous n'allons pas simplement attendre la
réaction de l'exécutif
nous allons au niveau du cdh à assurer
un suivi de la démarche et évite croyez
moi et les sénateurs vont être actif et
pas attentistes merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
voilà merci beaucoup alexandre donc on
le voit le sénat plutôt offensif est ce
que c'est une parole unis du sénat parce
que c'est un groupe de travail trans
partisan benjamin moral mais c'est tout
de même la majorité sénatoriale de
droite qui est maître d'oeuvre
mais s'ils voulaient faut faire un peu
l'historique c'est à dire qu emmanuel
macron demande des rapports aux
présidents des chambres qui vont être
remis aujourd'hui pour gérard larcher
pour richard fait rien pour le président
du cae mais en même temps ce sont des
rapports qu'ils demandent au président
qu'est ce que ça signifie est ce que ça
signifie l'un le on va dire
l'inspiration profonde du président qui
tout d'un coup écrire et sur un morceau
de table ce qu'il pense ou est-ce que ça
impliquerait qu'ils consultent
réellement la chambre il aurait demandé
de consulter la lettre n'est pas
vraiment très très clair si vous voulez
il y avait déjà un travail qui était
engagé au sénat un travail de la
majorité sénatoriale et la démarche de
gérard larcher s'était justement de
s'appuyer sur ce travail largement en
amont de la majorité sénatoriale en eau
en vue en effet la loi 3d avec en accord
avec les associations d'élus qui
elle-même présenteront leur son de
cloche la semaine prochaine le 8
on aura une contribution territoire du
mit de présenter des propositions sur la
décentralisation mais évidemment du coup
ce sont des propositions de la majorité
sénatoriale ouverte plutôt consensuel
mais de la majorité sénatoriale
il ya une résolution du parti socialiste
qui a été voté la semaine dernière qui
sera annexé à c'est à ces propositions
là et on voit que au sénat même il ya
plusieurs sons de cloche chez radioshack
brillé alors de travail c'est alors il
est évident que c'est une proposition de
la majorité
ceci étant dit beaucoup de groupes
parlementaires avaient commencé à
travailler très en amont pour remplir le
projet de loi 3d donc chacun avait
réfléchi sur les évolutions souhaitables
et quand on regarde ce qui a été fait
avant
et ce qui semble ressortir du projet du
sénat qu'on va découvrir tout à l'heure
on se rend compte qu'il ya quand même
énormément de points de convergence sur
toutes les questions je crois que le
fait que le groupe socialiste est sorti
sa propre résolution
même si beaucoup de choses semblent
converger aussi montre qu' il ya une
volonté d'identification personnelle
mais de façon générale je crois que au
moins sur les trois quarts du contenu il
va y avoir un accord il ya peut-être
plus d'accord aussi sur le constat que
sur toutes les propositions jean
baptiste forêt wima les libertés locales
font quand même partie de l'adn de l'adn
du sénat moi ce qui me frappe à la
lecture des premières pistes de ceux de
ce rapport c'est que la question des
fractures territoriales que quand même
été très présente à travers la la crise
des chemises jaunes et quand même
réduite à peau de chagrin dans ce dans
ce rapport et c'est une vraie question
qui se pose en particulier pour la
droite pour gérard larcher alors gérard
larcher lui représente plutôt ce que les
politologues appel classiquement la la
france du seigle et la châtaigne mais la
droite aussi c'est aussi la droite des
métropoles par exemple la droite de jean
luc moudenc qui président de france
humaine et qui dit très clairement il
faut absolument que les républicains est
un vrai corpus sur ces sujets là parce
qu'on est en train de prendre l'eau de
toute part enfin il n'y a plus que deux
merde de droite mâcon compatibles en
plus ils sont pas total sont pas 100 %
et l'ère jean loose christian estrosi à
nice et la réflexion sur ces sur ces
sujets là reste quand même très très
limité au sein de l'opposition
heller oui oui pour comprendre un peu 7
buts tout à fait pour comprendre cette
diversité également des propositions
sénatoriales faut quand même pas oublier
que dans quelques mois il ya des
sénatoriales
donc pour tous les groupes politiques il
faut montrer que ils sont en pôle
position pour défendre des élus en pole
position notamment pour défendre les
maires donc là il ya un enjeu si vous
voulez après sur le fond on voit très
clairement que est bien ce que va
pouvoir picorer emmanuel macron dans
l'ensemble de ces propositions n'est pas
tout à fait évident c'est à dire que
très clairement on voit qu emmanuel
macron mais lui même ses consultations
parlé tout à l'heure de la contribution
territoire unis mais il a reçu dominique
bussereau il a reçu
renaud muselier il a reçu françois
baroin mais également d'autres
associations représentatives du bloc
communal justement pour avoir une
diversité d'inspiration
donc il n'est pas dit que les
propositions du sénat servent réellement
de base de travail pour emmanuel macron
après il ya quelque chose dans lequel le
sénat ne semble pas vouloir s'aventurer
et dans laquelle la plupart des
associations d'élus ne semble pas non
plus vouloir s'aventurer
c'est le mécano territoriales c'est à
dire que l'idée de redessiner comme
l'évoqué douar philippe et quelques
jours devant l'assemblée nationale
le périmètre des collectivités voir les
différents niveaux de collectivités
n'apparaît pas tout à fait dans l'air du
temps à ce niveau là alors qu'on sait
que c'est peut-être une ambition d'
emmanuel macron avec en viser les
élections départementales et régionales
oui jean baptiste beuret oui le sénat
quand même en position de force 1 quand
même dans ce débat là puisqu'il a
l'appui des trois principales
associations d'élus l'association des
maires de france l'assemblée des
départements de france et régions de
france gérard larcher c'est un peu le
quatrième mousquetaire de la banda aux
côtés de renaud muselier de françois
baroin et de et de dominique bussereau
donc ils forment un bloc un bloc uni qui
va quand même peser beaucoup face face à
face à emmanuel macron et moins tout le
moins qu'on puisse dire aujourd'hui
c'est quand même que ce bloc n'a pas
fait de cadeau à emmanuel macron quand
même depuis depuis le début est
effectivement à quelques semaines des
sénatoriales
on peut s'attendre quand même un énième
bras de fer oui on se tient de l'autre
l'uni et que jamais et face à emmanuel
macron qu'il est en position de
faiblesse pour vous dans ce rapport là
ou pas écouté il finalement la pandémie
qui l'a mis en situation difficile lui
ordonne quand même un tout petit espoir
c'est qu'il est un peu en train de jouer
les départements contre les régions il
va jouer les collectivités les unes
contre les autres mais il est évident
que depuis plusieurs mois on a quand
même avec territoire tunis c'est la
première fois que je vois tous les
niveaux de collectivités territoriales
réfléchir ne serait-ce qu'à leur
vocation chacune leurs vocations
respectives
ils se sont interrogés sur qui devrait
faire quoi qui représente quoi quelle
est la nécessité pour les citoyens et
j'attends beaucoup aussi la semaine
prochaine le rapport territoire de
territoire unis parce que je ne sais pas
dans quelle mesure puisqu'on était en
train d'expliquer ce bloc y compris avec
le sénat dans quelle mesure il va y
avoir des différences et comment les
choses vont
ne vont pas être répétitif c'est assez
intéressant benjamin morel oui ça peut
être complémentaire ces propositions de
territoire unis par rapport à ce que
propose le sénat s'est déjà à un rapport
quand même fourni 50 propositions pour
sait que ça va être le même type de
mélodies probablement quand on sait
qu'en effet gérard larcher et le
quatrième mousquetaire de territoire
unis il est peu probable qu'ils aient
des oppositions radicales entre les deux
rapports la question même c'est
peut-être celle de l'utilité de ces deux
rapports alors il ya une légitimité de
territoire unis qui est campée sur la
représentativité de ces associations
d'élus qui d'ailleurs on l'a dit
contester par emmanuel macron et par le
gouvernement cette représentativité mais
qui malgré tout pèse notamment pour les
départements les régions et une grande
partie des communes et d'un autre côté
vous avez le sénat qui représentants des
territoires
donc on a deux légitimités concurrentes
on peut s'interroger sur l'idée et sur
la logique de cette opposition
dans les faits ça va probablement aller
dans le même sens et ça va en effet être
une pression supplémentaire sur emmanuel
macron qui promet de la décentralisation
mais semble déjà avoir une idée assez
précise de la décentralisation qui le
voudraient et qui n'est probablement pas
celle de gérard larcher qui n'est
probablement pas celle de territoire
unis cela alors que l'on voit que gérard
larcher le président du sénat et bien et
bien arrivé pour cette conférence de
presse qui devrait donc débuter d'un
instant à l'autre cette conférence de
presse qui va porter je vous le rappelle
sur les 50 propositions du sénat pour
une nouvelle génération de
décentralisation une conférence de
presse autour et bien de ces 50
propositions pour le plein exercice des
libertés locales
jean baptiste forêt on entendait aussi
et bien à bruno retailleau qui parlait
tout le temps de ses forces
contradictoires entre l'état et les
collectivités ça c'est un leit motiv
fois ci il ya toujours des forces
contradictoires entre l'un et l'autre
oui c'est un grand classique cette
opposition entre le pouvoir central et
le et le pouvoir local mais c'est vrai
que manuel macron d'une certaine façon à
face à lui les grands du royaume est en
fait qui qui sont entrés en fronde quand
même depuis depuis plusieurs années
maintenant donc je suis pas certain
effectivement kaka moins de deux ans
l'élection présidentielle tout le monde
réussisse à
accordez à accorder ses violons j'ajoute
quand même que ces trois associations
qui sont quand même majoritaires dans le
pays c'est à dire les républicains elles
n'ont pas forcément intérêt non plus à
se lancer dans un grand soir on aura
sans doute plus des petits matins qu'un
grand soir à l'issue de ce nouvel acte
de décentralisation est ce que ces
propositions peuvent répondre aux
attentes des français pour vous gérez
aline chavrier en cette sortie de crise
dans cette sortie de pandémie oui mais
alors attention c'est à dire que ça fait
déjà beaucoup d'années que les français
sont en attente de clarification au
niveau local et on a toujours parlé de
la décentralisation en termes
extrêmement technique
si on continue la à s'engager sur on va
faire la différenciation affaires de
tenues fiscale
on va rétablir la clause générale de
compétence ou pas ça va être aussi aussi
obscur que d'habitude ce qui peut
néanmoins changer les choses c'est je
crois qu'on va forcément repartir vers
un renforcement de la commune au niveau
local la commune a quand même été
extrêmement bouleversée depuis 2010 avec
un mouvement d'intercommunales isation
du territoire très brutale et on s'est
rendu compte bien avant la pandémie que
c'était vraiment une très mauvaise idée
avec la crise des gilet jaune que
démocratiquement parlant c'était une
catastrophe
je pense qu'il va y avoir des réponses
aux citoyens en termes de proximité mais
il va falloir vraiment pardon mois qu'il
ne le désirent pas toujours être
politique vraiment falloir créer ce
projet autour d'une idée démocratique de
partage des pouvoirs de nouvelle
citoyenneté pour reprendre les termes
qui existait quand on parlait de la
décentralisation en 1982 il va falloir
sortir de l'aspect technique et
institutionnel
oui si l'offre est relativement
technique c'est un vrai challenge bah
oui c'est un vrai challenge vous voulez
qu'il ne touchera d'ailleurs peut-être
pas que les collectivités territoriales
en faux billets qu emmanuel macron parle
des hôpitaux des universités dont qui a
promis il va provenant y avoir un grand
discours sur la liberté du terrain en
réalité mais ça reste relativement peu
vendeur 1 quand on demande aux français
quelles sont les priorités pour la fin
du quinquennat les 15 derniers mois dont
on parle et c'est très clairement pas la
décentralisation et s'est même pas les
réformes institutionnelles la
proportionnelle aux législatives etc
on voit que ces préoccupations là
arrivent tout au fond arrivées
arantza vendeur juste avant une
présidentielle c'est très compliqué oui
comment leur rendre audible
pour les français ce message
compréhensible alors que c'est vrai
c'est très important cette proximité
je suis pas persuadé que ça corresponde
à une attente profonde et des français
en fait les français sont quand même
plutôt jacobins dans l'âme ils veulent
un état ils veulent des préfets si on
s'en tient à ce qui s'est passé dimanche
on n'a pas de sens si quand même un
énorme appel aux pouvoirs au pouvoir
municipal à on a des maires qui sont
élus par moins de 20% de leurs de leur
corps électoral donc de ce point de vue
là ils sont quand même pas tellement en
position de force merci jean baptiste
fort et on va tout de suite se rejoindre
et bien cette conférence de presse de
gérard larcher le président du sénat
monsieur des rapporteurs qui sont ici
présents et les représentants des
groupes politiques et et françoise gatel
qui jouera le rôle de sage à la fois
pour mathieu darnaud et est elle même
présidente délégation dimanche dernier
pour la première fois c'est la france de
l'abstention qui a remporté les
élections municipales
ce constat doit nous interpeller car la
crise sanitaire ne peut tout expliquer
elle ne peut pas expliquer à une seule
une si faible participation
pour moi le mal est plus profond
le mal est plus ancien crise après crise
notre pays se fracture la défiance
s'installe c'est en réalité la crise du
manque de résultats que nous vivons je
crois que nos compatriotes avec la moins
de discours moins de bureaucratie et
plus de proximité
je crois que quel que soit notre
sensibilité
nous devons comprendre message que la
france nous adresser au delà même des
enjeux municipaux
oui crise après crise
les français constatent aussi le
délitement de l'état incapable de se
recentrer sur ses missions régaliennes
un état qui veut s'occuper de tout
régler tout mais à l'état au fonds
affaiblie et qui multiplie les fringues
initiatives des collectivités
territoriales et qui persiste à vouloir
imposer des règles uniformes
d'organisation qui au fond concrètement
éloigne les décisions des citoyens
seul un nouvel équilibre des pouvoirs
entre l'état les collectivités
territoriales me semble permettent de
restaurer la confiance est de donner un
nouvel élan à notre pays près de
quarante ans après les lois defferre
près de vingt ans après l'organisation
décentralisée de la république voulue
par jacques chirac la libre
administration et l'autonomie des
collectivités ne doivent plus être
simplement des mots mais traduire une
réalité complète
c'est le sens des 50 propositions pour
le plein exercice des libertés locales
que nous vous présentons aujourd'hui
avec philippe bas rapporteur général et
président de notre commission des lois
avec jean marie bockel co rapporteurs
président de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales au nom d'un
groupe de travail qui rassemble
l'ensemble des sensibilités du sénat
souvenez vous j'avais annoncé à
l'automne dernier lors de la succession
des congrès des associations d'élus
notre attention de contribuer à l'écrit
à l'écriture d'un nouvel acte de
décentralisation
d'ailleurs au regard de l'engagement
pris par le président de la république
au printemps un l'issue du grand débat
national
le lundi 13 janvier dans cette salle
même lors des voeux de territoire unis
j'avais jeté les bases de ce qui
pourrait être une nouvelle génération de
la décentralisation
c'était les mots que je prononçais à
cette occasion j'avais alors annoncé la
constitution d'un groupe de travail
sénatorial afin d'écrire le projet qui
vous est présentée et que j'ai fait
remettre ce matin au président de la
république nous avons mis en place ce
groupe de travail
concrètement le 26 février il est
composé des présidents de tous les
groupes politiques du sénat et deux
sénateurs particulièrement investie sur
ces questions au sein de notre assemblée
malgré la crise sanitaire les travaux se
sont poursuivis
ils se sont de fait enrichie des leçons
de l'expérience singulière que notre
pays a traversé notamment depuis le 17
mars dernier et s'est aussi enrichie de
l'audition d'élus locaux d'experts d'un
sondage confirmant la vision que les
français avaient des collectivités
territoriales et du rôle qu'ils
entendent qu'on leur confie avoir que
nos deux rapporteurs ne vous présente la
synthèse de ces 50 propositions pour le
plein exercice des libertés locales
je souhaite en donner l'esprit en
quelques mots le temps de la gouvernance
verticale de la sueur administration de
l'hypercentralisation me paraît révolu
si nous fallait une nouvelle preuve de
l'inefficacité du système
la crise sanitaire que nous avons
traversée nous la fournit la réactivité
des collectivités territoriales
à suppléer aux défaillances au
défaillance d'un état qui souvent n'a pu
répondre aux urgences du moment
je crois vraiment que les français et
leurs élus réclament plus de souplesse
moins de normes moins de contraintes et
une politique adaptée à la réalité de
chaque territoire
le législateur doit pouvoir confier les
compétences distinctes à des
collectivités territoriales appartenant
à une même catégorie
seule une véritable décentralisation me
paraît pouvoir répondre à cette
aspiration
seule une véritable décentralisation
peut permettre de retrouver confiance
cette confiance indispensable au
fonctionnement normal et apaisée d'une
démocratie c'est une confiance retrouvée
qui ratisse le lien entre les citoyens
et c'est la défiance qui conduis je
reprends à titres célèbres de cette
année à l'archet à l'archipel isation
d'une nation art chiper nisation mois
qui suit il y à l'île de batz je devrais
savoir ce que c'est qu'un archipel à
l'état déconcentré libérer de ses
pesanteurs de la multiplicité de ses
centres de décision
connecté à la réalité des territoires et
au quotidien de concitoyens
oui un état déconcentré pourra répondre
à cette volonté de rapprochement
l'organisation de l'état devra donc être
profondément transformé parce qu'en
france la république ne va pas sans état
et que le fédéralisme n'est pas dans nos
traditions politiques
nous voulons donner aux collectivités la
pleine et entière responsabilité de
compétences qu elles nous paraissent
pouvoir mieux exercer que l'état parce
qu'elles sont en proximité parce que
leur exercice pourrait être plus souple
et plus réactif
par exemple confié de nouvelles
compétences l'emploi et la santé
notamment le champ médico social mais
aussi des compétences pour mener la
transition écologique
j'ai fait mienne la formule que me
donnait le président de l'association
des maires du nord l'été dernier
l'écologie punitive venu d'en haut
divise l'écologie locale rassemble
mémoire aussi de ce qui s'était passé
avec la crise des gilets jaunes
il faut faciliter l'expérimentation de
politiques publiques qui soient adaptées
aux spécificités locales et qui puisse
être pérennisée par dérogation pour une
partie seulement du territoire
la situation des collectivités
d'outre-mer a fait l'objet d'un travail
spécifique et approfondie qui donnera
lieu d'ailleurs une publication
complémentaire du président de la
délégation collectivités territoriales
car elle appelle naturellement encore
plus de différenciation les régions les
départements les métropoles les communes
et leurs intercommunalités se sont font
de formidable laboratoire
d'expérimentation c'est aussi à partir
des initiatives locales que la relance
eux pourra se construire que la
transition écologique pourra trouver
toute sa dimension qu'elle pourrait être
comprise et partagée par les citoyens
sachant utiliser ses ressources la
france des territoires n'est pas
simplement une réalité géographique tel
sens et 50 propositions elle même reflet
de la diversité des opinions de l'esprit
de pragmatisme qui caractérise notre
assemblée
nos deux rapporteurs déposeront dans les
prochaines semaines les propositions de
loi constitutionnelle organique et
ordinaire qui déclineront ses pistes de
travail
ce n'est pas
tant l'organisation elle-même des
collectivités telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui qui est remise en cause mais
les conditions d'exercice des pouvoirs
locaux conditions d'exercice des
pouvoirs locaux qu'il faut transformer
en donnant collectivités territoriales
une liberté qui est nouvelle
celle de choisir leurs modalités
d'action et de coopération
les élections locales doivent redevenir
l'occasion pour les citoyens d'exprimer
une adhésion à un projet partagé avec
des élus proches du terrain
assumant des politiques de proximité qui
rompt retrouver une capacité à décider
en toute responsabilité car le mot
responsabilité est un mot aussi pour
nous important la démocratie locale est
une chance pour sortir notre pays de la
crise qu'il traverse et sanitaires les
économique et social et nous savons tous
que les semaines qui sont devant nous
vont être particulièrement difficile
mais aussi crise morale et aussi crise
de la représentation que nous avions
pressenti au travers des fractures
territoriales entre villes petites et
moyennes ruralité et métropole le
renforcement des libertés locales à
d'autres fins que le bénéficier à nos
concitoyens plus de liberté de créer
d'expérimenter d'entreprendre la
démocratie territoriale et les libertés
locales sont indissociables d'une
république une et indivisible
dans un pays fracture est divisée nous
voulons faire le pari de la liberté et
de la confiance j'étais un peu long par
2 les mois monsieur les rapporteurs je
voudrais remercier tous les membres du
groupe de travail qui j'allais dire son
beau couple engagé mais vous aurez
l'occasion de le dire mais c'est assez
rare que ce soit le président du sénat
qui préside lui même un groupe de
travail je les fais au travers de 40
propositions pour la révision
constitutionnelle
je vous le rappelle au printemps en
février 2018
c'est la seconde fois que je le fais
c'est aussi une signification importante
c'est dans le rôle même
constitutionnelle de notre assemblée sur
le président monsieur le président
messieurs les présidents sur collègues
mesdames et messieurs 50 propositions
c'est un bon chiffre c'est le numéro du
département de la manche monsieur le
président je pense que je pense que vous
l'avez fait exprès eux à l'au delà de
cette remarque je veux dire que notre
travail a été inspirée par la volonté de
prendre en compte tous les territoires
dans leur spécificité
que ce soit ceux de la france urbaine de
la france rurale ceux de la métropole de
l'outre-mer et quelles que soient les
catégories de collectivités qui forment
le bloc des collectivités territoriale
de notre pays
comme le président l'a souligné à la
source de notre travail
il y a la volonté d'affirmer notre
attachement aussi à l'unité nationale et
à l'état ce sont les instruments de
l'égalité ce sont les instruments de la
cohésion
ce sont aussi les instruments de la
puissance face au reste du monde
c'est donc pour nous une exigence
fondamentale au moment de parler des
libertés locales et de la
décentralisation que de rappeler cet
attachement
face à toutes les forces de divisions
qui sont à l'oeuvre dans notre société
mais justement justement nous pensons
que l'unité est plus forte dans la
liberté et dans la confiance je reprends
le mot du président elle est plus forte
dans le dialogue et la pratique de la
délégation que dans une centralisation
qui agit traditionnellement dans notre
pays comme un étouffoir des initiatives
par l' asphyxie des libertés locales
le défi pour notre pays c'est donc de
trouver une ligne de crête entre
centralisme et fédéralisme et cette
ligne de crête au fond elle est déjà
inscrite dans notre constitution
c'est l'organisation décentralisée de la
république il faut aller au bout de
l'organisation décentralisée de la
république il faut franchir un point de
non retour
il faut bien sûr éviter de nouveaux
coups de boutoir dans l'organisation de
nos collectivités territoriales éviter
le big bang éviter l'instabilité et la
déstabilisation mais il faut en même
temps savoir être ambitieux pour donner
un nouvel élan à notre pays
vaste ambition mes ambitions nécessaire
en france l'administration centrale n'a
de cesse de récupérer les pouvoirs que
la loi donne aux collectivités
territoriales l'administration centrale
récupère les pouvoirs par l'argent et
par la norme l'autonomie financière
des collectivités territoriales tend à
devenir un vain mot
tandis que les compétences attribuées
par le législateur aux collectivités
sont reprises par l'état d'une autre
main par la multiplication des normes
qui encadre par décret mais aussi par
simple circulaire l'exercice de ses
compétences dans notre pays
ce n'est pas la décentralisation
ce ne sont pas les libertés locales qui
nous sont naturels c'est le centralisme
qui naturel c'est pourquoi si on laisse
les choses aller sur leur r on est
absolument certain que cette tendance
qui est un héritage de l'histoire va se
poursuivre pour la décentralisation nous
avons besoin d'une forte volonté
politique qui s'exerce dans la durée et
donc notre ambition le défi qui est à
relever aujourd'hui c'est un défi majeur
c'est de pouvoir donner un coup d'arrêt
que j'espère historique à la
centralisation
c'est toute l'inspiration de notre
travail sous l'impulsion que nous a
donnée le président du sénat qui a
conduit et ses travaux sur six mois mais
ces travaux ne sont pas les premiers
travaux du sénat sur ces matières ils
font suite à un travail que rappellera
jean marie bockel de la délégation
collectivités territoriales mais aussi
aux travaux menés au sein de la
commission des lois notamment par
mathieu dans l'eau et françoise gatel
sur les questions de décentralisation
qu'est-ce qui a été le plus important
pour nous je vais pas vous résumer 50
propositions
vous en prendrez connaissance nous
pourrons en discuter ensuite c'est
d'abord d'empêcher à l'avenir que l'état
comme il l'a fait dans le passé récupère
les pouvoirs qu'ils décentralise
notre deuxième objectif c'est de
protéger la commune il ne faut pas que
la commune devienne une coquille vide
il faut que les maires puissent
continuer à assumer devant leurs
concitoyens des responsabilités
consistante
la troisième chose c'est de garantir
l'indépendance financière des
collectivités la quatrième c'est de
permettre à chaque catégorie de
collectivités les régions les
départements les intercommunalités les
communes d'avoir des compétences à
géométrie variable autour d'un tronc
commun plus de souplesse plus de liberté
sans jamais opposé france rurale et
france urbaine
enfin il faut penser à l'état l'état
n'est plus capable de s'engager auprès
des collectivités
tout remonte au préfet de région aux
agences qui sont organisées par l'état
au plan régional
tout remonte aussi aux administrations
centrales
il n'y a pas de décentralisation
possible si on ne donne pas au préfet du
département le pouvoir de décider
souvent à la place qu'occupe aujourd'hui
le préfet de région
tout s'est passé en deux temps d'abord
on a réuni les fonctionnaires au plan
régional ensuite on a fait les grandes
régions si bien que les pouvoirs de
décisions de l'état sont très éloignés
des collectivités qui ont besoin d'un
interlocuteur étatique capable de
s'engager alors à partir de ces
finalités nous avons fait 50
propositions
les quatre principales pour moi c'est ma
sensibilité
c'est de dire dans la constitution qui
décident paie qu'à chaque fois qu'une
norme nouvelle va devoir être appliquée
par une collectivité
la constitution impose au gouvernement
de prévoir des délégués à cette
collectivité les moyens nécessaires le
deuxième c'est de décréter un moratoire
sur la réforme des finances locales
on ne peut pas remplacer des bases
stables même imparfaite peur des
ressources sensibles à la conjoncture
on ne peut pas déshabiller paul pour
habiller pierre
on ne peut pas remplacer la taxe
d'habitation par un impôt qui profitent
actuellement au département et remplacer
cet impôt départemental par une fraction
de tva dans le produit s'écroule en cas
de crise économique ce que nous voyons
un instant il faut revoir la boucle donc
ce moratoire est aussi une proposition à
mes yeux très importante
la troisième proposition à mon avis
essentiel c'est d'arrêter de dépouiller
les communes aussi bien au plan
intercommunal que en encadrant les
pouvoirs des communes par l'état et donc
il faut que la commune ne devienne
jamais une collectivité spécialisés il
faut que le conseil municipal puisse
traiter de tous les besoins de la
population de la commune il faut donc
que la clause générale de compétence de
la commune soit inscrite dans la
constitution pour qu'aucun législateur
de demain ne puisse la remettre en cause
enfin me paraît essentiel de donner aux
collectivités les moyens de régler les
problèmes auxquels l'état ne parvient
pas à apporter de solutions il s'agisse
de l'emploi et de la formation au niveau
régional mais aussi de l'organisation de
l'offre de soins qu'il s'agisse pour les
départements de créer des blocs un bloc
de compétences sociales alors que les
compétences sociales sont dispersés d'un
côté l' agence régionale de santé
de l'autre les caisses d'allocations
familiales et c'est aussi de permettre
et évidemment à la commune de pouvoir
réagir à toute situation
on a vu à quel point le président de
rappeler à l'instant dans la crise que
nous venons de traverser est cuit
qui subsistent encore la crise sanitaire
du coc vide 19 les collectivités et
d'abord les communes ont répondu présent
il nous appartiendra maintenant monsieur
le président de traduire ces
propositions certaines relèvent de la
constitution d'autres relèveront de la
loi organique et les plus importantes
relèveront de la loi ordinaire
c'est un travail auquel nous nous
attelons à partir d'aujourd'hui avec
l'intention de rendre publics des
propositions de loi au cours ce mois de
juillet pouvoir les mettre à la
disposition bien sûr non seulement des
associations d'élus mais aussi du
président de la république et du
gouvernement
c'est un travail en commun que nous
souhaitons engager
nous y sommes prêts nous avons pris une
certaine avance et nous entendons la
garder
merci monsieur le président nous
arrivons aujourd'hui à la conclusion
d'un travail au long cours le président
du sénat l'a rappelé tout à l'heure et
je veux mon tour salué la qualité de la
méthode suivie avec un véritable
partenariat de confiance avec philippe
bas et aussi entre nos équipes de la
commission des lois et de la délégation
aux collectivités territoriales soutenu
par une implication personnelle
constante du président larcher avec
l'ensemble des groupes ici représentée
en soutien bien sûr françoise gatel et
mathieu darnaud qui ont la double
appartenance entre la commission des
lois et la délégation et surtout qui ont
fait un travail sur engagement et
proximité qui nous a bien aidés c'est
pourquoi nous voulons aujourd'hui vous
présenter des propositions ça a déjà été
dit avec je crois vous le sentez bien
avec un véritable contenu
alors que le gouvernement en est encore
aux effets d'annoncé avec son projet de
loi 3d au moment d'entamer nos travaux
en février dernier il m'a paru en ce qui
me concerne essentiel de prendre un peu
de recul pour examiner ce que
nous attendions à l'époque de la
décentralisation de 1981 que j'ai voté
et qui avait suscité un réel espoir car
au fond c'est toujours sur cette lancée
que nous trouvons dans son fameux
discours à l'assemblée nationale le 27
juillet 1981
j étais gaston defferre lancé quatre
idées force sur les objectifs de la
réforme
premièrement il s'agissait de libérer et
lui entreprises
je cite d'un dirigisme étouffant et de
fonctionnaires et ministres lointain je
cite toujours qu'ils connaissent mal
leurs problèmes on est dans le contexte
de l'époque m'enfin
c'était des propos forts deuxième idée
je cite c'est renforcer la démocratie
que de permettre aux élus de décider sur
place des solutions à apporter aux
problèmes qu'ils connaissent mieux que
quiconque au coeur de la nouvelle action
publique devait donc déjà à l'époque se
trouvait la proximité troisième idée il
s'agissait de répondre aux besoins de
participation et de concertation des
citoyens avec je cite un premier pas
vers une nouvelle citoyenneté
enfin le ministre de l'intérieur de
l'époque affirmé je cite c'est renforcer
l'état que de l'alléger d'une partie des
tâches dont il s'est encombrée
progressivement et qu'il n'arrive pas à
accomplir de manière satisfaisante
c'était il ya près de 40 ans aujourd'hui
où en sommes nous
force est de reconnaître que nous sommes
loin du compte sur ces quatre objectifs
paradoxe des textes s'accumulent pour
décentraliser davantage jusqu'à une
ambitieuse révision constitutionnelle en
2003 qui a cependant produit peu
d'effets comme le rappelait
régulièrement philippe bas lors de nos
travaux et pourtant la recentralisation
avant ce second paradoxe cette
recentralisation
bien loin de renforcer l'état le
fragilise en le sommant de tout faire et
donc de tout mal faire la vérité est que
l'état ne permet pas l'épanouissement du
mouvement décentralisateur il s'est
immiscé dans la gestion des compétences
territoriales par une succession de lois
bavarde et désordonnée le parlement les
majorités successives lui ont
certainement eu aussi un peu leurs parts
balayons devant nos portes aussi par
l'exercice de son pouvoir réglementaire
normative par l'intervention de ses
administrations par ces sois budget de
par ses choix budgétaires par ces
contraintes sur les ressources propres
des collectivités et par une
contractualisation dite de cahors très
déséquilibré au détriment des
territoires et aujourd'hui cahors
de l'avis de tous y compris de
l'exécutif c'est un peu le contre
exemple de ce qu'il ne faut plus faire
si on veut sauver l'esprit de
contractualisation ce qui apparaît
d'ailleurs aussi dans nos propositions
alors lorsque président larcher
souhaitait que nous réfléchissions à
l'avenir de la décentralisation
nous avons voulu ensemble faire oeuvre
non pas conjoncturelle avec un texte de
plus un rapport de plus mais bien
structurelle et avec l'idée ça a été dit
à l'instant de décliner très vite la
démarche à l'exécutif d'en prendre son
miel mais à nous aussi de veiller dès à
présent à ce que concrètement ces
cinquante propositions apparaissent dans
les textes qui ont été évoqués à
l'instant c'est important c'est aussi un
élément de la volonté forte qui incarne
notre démarche et de sa crédibilité
parmi nous se compose de proposition
vous en trouverez donc au delà de leurs
rédactions libre et mesuré qui cache de
petite révolution et devrait nous
permettre de stopper l'insidieuse
dynamique centralisatrice notre
délégation la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales il ya
particulièrement travailler parce que sa
vocation voulu et réaffirmée
régulièrement par le président du sénat
et de protéger des collectivités
territoriales de porter leur voix au
choeur des institutions de la république
c'est en écoutant les ai vus leurs
associations que nous avons proposé ces
avancées les annexes du document
d'ailleurs sont intéressantes parce
qu'elle relate le détail du travail à la
fois du sénat depuis longtemps comme
philippe le rappeler mais également tout
le travail que nous avons fait en
parallèle je disais souvent pour la
délégation le travail fournisseurs 1 qui
chemin faisant et je le dis devant
plusieurs que les dc présent de toutes
sensibilités nous a permis de nourrir
cette démarche
et pour finir je vais simplement donner
quelques exemples qui concrets qui en
complément de ce qui vient d'être dit
par philippe nous paraissent importants
qui apparaissent d'ailleurs
essentiellement dans la quatrième partie
du rapport nous proposons ainsi
proposition 32 une évaluation a
posteriori à trois ou cinq ans de
l'impact réel sur les collectivités
territoriales des textes adoptés avec
comme aiguillon parce que nous savons
que notre pays manque de culture de
l'évaluation le fait que les textes
concernés deviendrait caduc
en l'absence de cette évaluation on est
un peu dans la rubrique on se connaît
bien que naughty ses automnes connais
toi toi même nous connaissons un peu les
faiblesses françaises presque culturel à
côté de nos grandes forces
1 et bien donc donnons nous les moyens
de vérifier de nous n'ont les moyens
d'évaluer un le diable et parfois dans
les détails et c'est pas des détails
plus audacieux encore proposition 46
nous avons souhaité créer une nouvelle
catégorie de résolution les résolutions
territoriales qui seront une mise en
écho des préoccupations des territoires
au sein des institutions nationales de
même proposition 48 et c'est mon dernier
exemple nous avons prévu d'instituer un
mécanisme de contrôle de la suppression
des chevauchements de compétences
on dit qu'on va le faire la clarté la
clarification mais après il ya plus qu'à
faire et là il faut être attentif il
faut contrôler la la mise en oeuvre et
donc de la suppression de ces
chevauchements de compétences entre
l'état des collectivités et notre
délégation la délégation aux
collectivités se verra confier ce
travail le mérite de cette proposition
est d'être simple à mettre en oeuvre
puisqu'il suffit d'intégrer dans notre
règlement
voilà je suis heureux
moi aussi que nous soyons parvenus à un
résultat à la fois équilibré et
audacieux équilibrée parce que nos
propositions ne vont pas à l'encontre de
la solidarité entre les territoires
pas plus qu'elle ne fragilise l'unité
nationale au contraire nous souhaitons
des collectivités territoriales fortes
et responsable au coeur de l'action de
proximité mais épaulé par un état
conscient de ses missions propres
on a vu dans la région de crise que il à
ses missions propres ailes c'est
important conscients qu'ils âge de ses
missions propres est capable de
mobiliser les moyens nécessaires pour
les exercer efficacement audacieux parce
que si ces propositions sont mises en
oeuvre nul doute que nous n'en sortent
que nous aurons sorti la
décentralisation de l'ornière merci à
jean marie bockel donc maintenant à vous
de d'interroger notamment les les
rapporteurs sur l'ensemble des sujets ce
travail qui a rassemblé notamment autour
des présidents de groupe mais les
collègues parmi les plus investis ont
donné lieu à des contributions qui ont
été annexées à ce rapport et qui montre
aussi la diversité d'un certain nombre
d' approche
la semaine dernière il ya eu par exemple
une proposition de résolution socialiste
qui a fait l'objet d'un débat ici même
au céda et que vous retrouverez en
annexe avec d'autres propositions
d'autres réflexions portant sur le
statut de l'élu sur lequel il y a aussi
des réflexions qu'ils ont prises en
compte alors qu'ils commencent qui
souhaitent poser des questions à nos
rapporteur on commence par vous et on va
vous tendre le micro la voilà vous
présenter et on essaye de vous apporter
les réponses
bonjour je suis content qu'elle mais je
serais pour public sénat j'ai une
question pour vous monsieur larcher au
début du mois de juin le président
public vous a proposé de faire eh bien
vous vos propositions sur les priorités
essentielles pour la suite du
quinquennat
est ce que au delà de ce que vous avez
pu lui proposer dans vos 50 mesures ici
pouvez nous dire ce qu raoult ce qu'il y
a dans ses propositions que vous allez
transmettre à emmanuel macron et comment
est ce que vous avez perçu cette main
tendue vers une concorde comment est-ce
que les ai vécus vous et gérard larcher
tout d'abord c'est hier après midi que
le président de la république a convié
les deux autres présidents de
l'assemblée nationale
des conseillers économiques sociales et
environnementales et moi-même venir
échanger avec lui sur la base de la
demande qu'il avait fait le 3 juin
dernier et sur lequel je lui avais
répondu que bien sûr il y avait un
certain nombre de propositions
beaucoup lui ont été transmises à
l'occasion d'un déjeuner que nous avions
souhaité les présidents de groupe et moi
même avec le président de la république
donc ce travail de suggestions la
semaine passée a été fait par l'ensemble
des présidents de groupe
cet après midi je présenterai et deux
sujets sur lequel il y à contribution
collective et non pas individuelle parce
que moi je préside une assemblée
collectives collégiales de 348 sénateurs
avec une diversité politique et de
sujets nous ont paru important traité de
manière différente
un sujet que nous avions entamé bien
avant cette demande
le sujet qui fait l'objet plein exercice
des collectivités locales et le sujet de
la réorganisation de notre système de
santé qui fait l'objet d'une note dieu
président milon qui m'est adressée et
une note dans lequel ils annexent
l'ensemble des rapports faits par des
collègues de sensibilité différente sur
les sujets de santé et d'autonomie
depuis maintenant six années et c'est au
tour de sa queue
ce rapport tiendra voilà des choses
telles qu'elles sont de toute façon ici
au sénat comme l'a rappelé le président
bas seront déposés les propositions de
loi constitutionnelle organique est
proposition de loi ordinaire pour
décliner comme le l'avions fait 2018 en
juin pour sortir un peu d'éléments
bloquante issu de la loi d'autres et qui
ont nourri engagement et et proximité je
pense que l'union nationale parce que
vous utilisiez le sénat l'a démontré
dans les périodes de crise au travers
notamment de projet de loi d'urgence le
rapporteur amont bâbord cet instant
auprès du projet de loi de finances
rectificative qui ne veut pas dire qu'il
n'ya pas débat discussion
nous sommes dans une logique
d'enrichissement des textes voire de
manifestation un certain nombre de
désaccords ce qui a été le cas sur le
dernier texte d'urgence car ici vous
savez combien nous sommes attachés aux
libertés
oui bonjour tiré du pont pour contexte
j'avais deux questions la première c'est
est ce que vous pourriez nous dire quels
sont les textes qui vont être présentés
en priorité et ce qui vous savez déjà ce
que vous allez présenter comme
proposition de loi monsieur le président
bat hull laboratoire est là et je pose
petit ma deuxième question qui est un
peu plus générale le président de la
république lorsqu'il a reçu les citoyens
les membres de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat a parlé peut-être
d'inscrire dans la constitution des
choses liées aux à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique dans vos
propositions vous vous parlez d'inscrire
dans la constitution des choses liées
aux collectivités locales
est ce qu'il y a un deal en préparation
c'est aussi pour le même
nos propositions monsieur forme un tout
ce n'est pas une liste de course dans
laquelle on pourrait picorer le but
c'est effectivement de franchir un
palier et un point de non retour
donc nous n'allons pas égrainé dans le
temps les propositions nous allons tout
les préparer pour les sortir au cours du
mois de juillet et ensuite ils seront
sur la table près être délibéré par le
parlement les dispositions
constitutionnelles j'en ai mentionné
quelques-unes faire en sorte que que
soit inscrite dans la constitution le
principe selon lequel qui décident paix
la clause générale de compétence des
communes le droit à la différenciation
pour l'outre-mer réunir les articles 73
et 74 de la constitution pour que les
collectivités qui le souhaiteraient
puisse acquérir de nouvelles compétences
m aussi la possibilité que par principe
quand la loi régit des compétences
locales ça n'est pas au décret de
déterminer les modalités d'application
de la loi mais au pouvoir réglementaire
locale ceci relève de la constitution de
même que relève de la constitution la
notion de ressources propres des
collectivités territoriales et donc il y
a là un certain nombre de garanties
justement dans cette idée de franchir un
point de non retour et d'empêcher les la
recentralisation que nous voulons
inscrire au niveau constitutionnel
l'organique aura également des éléments
à apporter notamment s'agissant des
études d'impact qui aujourd'hui sont
largement vidés de leur substance
qu'elle puisse se prononcer sur les
faits sur les collectivités
territoriales des législations que nous
adoptons et qu'elles puissent aussi ses
études d'impact vivre dans le temps en
obligeant le gouvernement à évaluer les
lois et à revenir devant le parlement
pour présenter leurs
leur impact réel après avoir présenté
les pronostics que l'on peut faire sur
l'impact et puis les propositions
d'ordre législatif c'est toutes les
autres je ne rentre pas dans le détail
mais il me semble que tous doivent
cheminer ensemble et que c'est même
essentiel pour le succès de la réforme
il faut à défaut de big bang qu'il y ait
tout de même dans notre pays
une ère nouvelle des libertés locales
qu'ils soient explicitement ouverte
voilà ce que je voulais venir sur la
convention
oui les propositions des 150 citoyens
tirés au sort et sont à la fois riche et
est intéressante et nous sommes tous au
sénat notamment à travers nos
expériences de mandats locaux
je les ai vécus en étant un des
pionniers des conseils de quartier et
d'autres conseils consultatifs
nous croyons et nous croyons depuis
longtemps qu'en complément de la
démocratie représentative
la démocratie participative sous toutes
ses formes y compris les formes les plus
actuels constitue un plus important mais
nous avons en tout cas en ce qui me
concerne j'ai aussi et je ne suis pas le
seul la conviction que la crise que
traverse actuellement notre démocratie à
travers le très fort taux d'abstention y
compris pour des élections locales
municipales n'a pas comme solution
l'effacement de la démocratie
représentative
au contraire il faut qu'elle garde toute
sa place mais que la dimension de projet
de proposition de leadership pour les
mettre en oeuvre doit contribuer à
recréer la confiance et au niveau
notamment des territoires nos
propositions vont dans ce sens à la fois
réenchanter comme l'on dit hein mais
également donner du contenu à cette
démarche
ça servira aussi la crédibilité
nécessaire en la démocratie
représentative simplement attention pas
réinventer des choses qui existent jeu
rappelle que dans la loi économie
circulaire nous avons déjà traité et
rapporteur madame de sidrac à très très
clairement des choses qui font partie
des conclusions de la convention de
citoyenne sur la sphère du reporting
financier
nous avons déjà ce point traité en 2019
sur la loi d'orientation des mobilités
le sénat s'est particulièrement penché
sur les questions de billettique et nous
venons d'avoir un rapport sur le bilan
carbone du numérique
vous voyez que il faut au delà
peut-être que nous partagions tous plus
collectivement
et puis il ya des sujets qui sont pas
traités comme le nucléaire par exemple
des énergies non carbonées
c'est des sujets sur lequel j'ai vu dans
la conclusion de ce qui était une île
que dont certains étaient venus me
rencontrer que quand même il confié au
parlement et à l'exécutif
je crois que ne pouvoir avoir la place
de la démocratie représentative qui est
une clé de voûte dans une démocratie
sans opposer les uns aux autres alors je
vois d'autres questions alors ici
d'abord ici là je sais pas qui tendait à
l'aise il a les yeux lisier bons
messieurs j'ai deux questions ses fans
du gain le télégramme j'ai deux
questions à vous poser sur deux volets
de vos propositions qui sont pas
d'ailleurs vraiment surprenante
la première concerne la réaffirmation de
la pertinence de la queue générale de
compétence alors j'entends bien mais
est-ce qu'il n'ya pas potentiellement un
risque de malentendu dans la mesure où
ça confie potentiellement au maire des
responsabilités qu'ils n'auront pas les
moyens d'assumer alors même qu'on voit
bien que la vraie difficulté aux yeux
des administrés et de comprendre qui
fait quoi et qui a le bon niveau de
compétence c'est ma première question ma
seconde question qu concept le concerne
le concept de différenciation que je
distingue de celui d'évaluation
j'entends bien qu'il est à la mode mais
au fond là aussi n'y at-il pas le risque
que différenciation ap
boudissa une distorsion de l'égalité sur
les territoires qui me semble être
encore un principe républicain
fondamental
merci monsieur de ces questions la
question des moyens de la commune et
celle des compétences évidemment elles
sont indissociables c'est la raison pour
laquelle on ne peut pas avancer dans la
protection de la compétence générale de
la commune sans avancer aussi sur le
chapitre des moyens est également sur le
chapitre des relations entre communes et
communautés de communes ou
d'agglomération et c'est pourquoi je
disais tout à l'heure que nos
propositions forme d'un tout parce
qu'ils ne serviraient en effet à rennes
ou à pas grand-chose de défendre la
clause de compétence générale de la
commune dans la constitution si nous ne
prenions pas dans le même élan des
dispositions sur les moyens et sur les
rapports entre communes et
intercommunalités dans le domaine de
l'intercommunalité c'est très frappant
quand on prend un peu de recul par
rapport à un historique que d'une
trentaine d'années de constater que tous
nos systèmes y compris financiers ont
poussé non seulement à la création de
grandes communautés mais aussi à faire
en sorte que plus la communauté est
grande plus elle doit exercer de
compétences la crainte que la commune
devienne une coquille vide dans ce
contexte est réel et par conséquent pour
les trente années qui viennent il faut
réinventer l'intercommunalité par un
rééquilibrage entre intercommunalités et
communes ce qui suppose que dans
l'attribution des moyens on cesse
d'inciter à l'intégration la plus grande
mais qu'au contraire on met en place un
système qui assure la neutralité des
financements pour le territoire par
rapport aux modes d'organisation des
rapports entre communes et communautés
ça c'est le chapitre des moyens mais
précisément je crois que
tant de mer tant de communes voient
leurs responsabilités aujourd'hui
diminuée au point que les habitants mais
vous le disiez vous mêmes ne savent plus
qui est responsable
au point que les maires n'assume pas les
décisions de l'intercommunalité et
désigne l'intercommunalité comme étant
extérieur à la commune alors que la
commune est actionnaire de la communauté
de communes en quelques sortes
et bien ce processus là était sans doute
un point de passage nécessaire mais il
est allé trop loin et nous voulons le
rééquilibrage voilà ce que je peux dire
pour répondre à votre première question
est ce que jean marie répond sur la
différenciation encore que phillipe
hauray puis répondre parfaitement
puisque nous avons beaucoup partagé y
compris avec le président bien sûr sur
ce sujet je pense que votre question
enfin moi je la gela je la trouve
vraiment importante
nous avons rappelé d'ailleurs tous les
trois un notre attachement à l'unité
nationale notre attachement à un certain
nombre de règles qui sont également à
une forme de respect de l'égalité entre
les territoires
ce qu'on veut éviter alors que on passe
progressivement de l'expérimentation à
la différenciation sujet sur lequel nous
avons beaucoup travaillé y compris cher
hervé marseille et dans notre groupe
comme dans d'autres groupes d'ailleurs
c'est d'éviter une différenciation au
fil de l'eau et qui peut à ce moment là
à un moment ou un autre avec de la
surenchère ici ou là constitué à risque
et je pense que 1 des intérêts aussi de
notre travail c'est de fixer un cadre
clair à la démarche pour que l puisse se
mettre en oeuvre
chaque fois que les conditions sont
réunies sans remettre en cause ce cadre
et c'est d'ailleurs aussi une manière de
donner sa juste place à la
différenciation sinon c'est le grand
n'importe quoi et nous avons ça à
l'esprit
même si on va essayer de donner des
réponses plus qu on pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de questions françois jarret
horizon politique je vous pose une
question de temps
parlez bien dans le micro oui le
président de la république a dit qu'il
souhaitait faire une nouvelle étape de
la décentralisation
il ya un projet de loi organique dit 3d
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas
attendu que le gouvernement présente ses
ses dispositions pour éventuellement
présenter les vôtres et amender ce que
le gouvernement peut faire parce que
pardonnez-moi la démarche du parlement
c'est pas simplement de votre les textes
qu'on nous envoie en les amendes ans est
aussi de faire des propositions
nous sommes législateur réacteurs de
proposition et que d'ailleurs en matière
de collectivités territoriales c'est
juste après le vote de la loi d'autre
que la commission des lois a mis en
place un groupe de suivi les lois
territoriale qu'elles se sont succédé à
certain nombre de collègues pensent eux
gatel qui est là pourra vous en dira
boel suisse a aussi avec mathieu dardot
aujourd'hui c'est donc notre rôle b
président il dit autre chose je vais
renverser la table
eh ben nous lui disons moi je lui dis
politiquement chichis chiche
la compétence santé la compétence emploi
est ce que c'est ça c'est ça vraiment
s'engager et je crois que autour de ça
la compétence sociale pour les
départements présent a dit devant les
présidents de groupe
le département au g aujourd'hui n'est
qu'un guichet liquidateur sommes
d'accord il faut que le département et
la plénitude de cette responsabilité et
qui construisent tout cela d'ailleurs
avec communes et intercommunalités qui
joue un rôle social voilà et dont aucun
nous sommes dans une attitude positive
attentive en même temps exigeante et je
dis chiche
monsieur
je m'inscris un petit peu dans la foulée
de la question de mon confrère
j'avoue ma perplexité parce que j'ai le
sentiment que au fil des crises
successives que ce soit chez les jeunes
et puis maintenant cette crise sanitaire
économique et social il ya eu une
évolution qui est un cheminement qui
s'est produit du côté de l'exécutif j'en
prends pour témoins l'intervention du
président de la république le 13 le 13
juin avec une porte ouverte et j'ai le
sentiment peut-être que je me trompe
qu'il y aurait des points d'accroché
important des points de rapprochement
important entre vos propositions ce qui
est en train de mûrir du côté de
l'exécutif etc
vous disiez tout à l'heure que vous
étiez prêts un travail commun et c'est
là que je m'interroge effectivement sur
en même temps vous dit nos propositions
c'était tout il n'ya pas picorer dedans
et nous avons pris de l'avancé nous
entendons la garder ce qu'est ce que
c'est si ce n'est une sorte de déjà se
mettre en position de concurrence avec
avec les avec l'exécutif
alors qu'il ya là des passerelles qui me
semble évidente alors racing guerrero
perplexité la deuxième des choses je
vais demander au président bah de vous
répondre mais nous nous sommes un
accélérateur et pas qu'un accélérateur
de particules mais un accélérateur parce
que pardonnez moi jusque là je n'ai pas
vu la verticalité encore s'inverser
j'avais envie de répondre un peu dans le
même sens que pour qu'il y ait
concurrence il faut qu'il y ait des
compétiteurs j'entends bien sûr les
discours mais nous sommes nous en train
de présenter des propositions elles sont
sur la table
3d j'en entends parler aussi
mais je ne les ai pas encore vus tandis
que nos propositions vous les voyez et
le parlement n'est pas une institution
qui devrait être à la remorque des
initiatives de l'exécutif
moi je ne le vis pas comme ça je trouve
que c'est dans notre rôle de
représentation nationale avec une
discussion entre toutes les forces
politiques du pays qui sont représentés
dans nos assemblées de faire des
propositions c'est pas une compétition
c'est une mission constitutionnelle je
m'étonne qu'on puisse s'étonner que le
parlement fasse des propositions tout de
même la cinquième république n'en est
pas tout à fait arrivée là d'autres
questions oui c'est dans la tribune
c'est un peu aussi en rebond avec ce que
vous venez de dire messieurs les
présidents wayne quand j'ai écouté le
président la république le jour j'avais
l'impression d'écouter présent la
république dans sa lettre aux français
de janvier 2019 et le conférence de
presse posée au grand débat national 19
toujours les mêmes phrases tout ne doit
pas être décidée à paris il faut
réorganiser d'état donc franchement est
ce que vous y croyez vraiment et même si
j'ose dire est-ce que c'est pas un coup
de com avant les sénatoriales qui vont
arriver très vite
je vais donner un homme deux fois
l'occasion pour répondre alors sur la
référence aux élections sénatoriales
je vais vous dire la réponse est oui
les élections sénatoriales sont un
rendez vous démocratique l'ensemble des
sénateurs de tous les groupes se
retrouvent avec leur sensibilité propre
leur différence dans cette démarche
le président l'a rappelé 1 toute
personne qui a fait une campagne
sénatoriale
ça nous est arrivé fait état du travail
de l'institution à laquelle on
appartient
et même par rapport aux gens qui nous
écoutent les électeurs les élus les
maires ses premiers avant l'étiquette
politique que par ailleurs
chacun a la fierté d'assumer et donc
c'est très bien qu'il en soit ainsi et
c'est attendu et on attend que le sénat
soit force de proposition et nous le
sommes et d'une certaine manière le
chiche du président le chiche du
président larcher à l'instant 1 par
rapport à ce travail c'est qu'à un
moment donné on saisisse la perche on
propose de se mettre autour d'une table
peut être aussi des députés qui ont fait
des propositions et qu'à ce moment là on
rentre dans le concret de ce qui est
possible avec quel calendrier de ski ça
ce serait formidable
1 et quand vous dites au début de votre
propos est ce que vous y croyez
mais bien sûr que nous y croyons et nous
y croirons toujours mais parce que il y
à l'amour et les preuves d'amour 1
nous continuons la démarche comme a
rappelé tout à l'heure le président et
philippe bas à travers cette ce dépôt de
textes qui va en quelque sorte assurer
notre esprit constructif
une autre question oui bonjour je
voudrais vous demander comment on va s'y
retrouver entre toutes ces propositions
il ya donc les 50 d'aujourd'hui il va y
avoir des propositions de territoire
unis il y à vos propres positions au
président de la république et même même
chose versant assemblée nationale
c'est très simple parce que qu'ils
votent la loi si ce n'est nous qu on
cherche de faire la synthèse mais je
donne la parole au président de la
commission des lois le président vous a
répondu je crois
abondance de biens ne nuit pas et on
verra ce qui nous permettra d'être le
plus pertinent le plus efficace
l'important c'est que nous avons situer
le niveau de l'ambition
nous sommes montrés disponibles pour un
travail commun
ce dont nous ne voulons pas c'est d'un
enterrement de première classe de la
décentralisation de nouveau en retombant
dans les vieilles ornières et nous
souhaitons naturellement que toutes les
propositions dont vous faites état soit
aussi audacieuse que les nôtres c'est
vraiment notre voeu le plus cher et
c'est pas dans l'intérêt des élus ou des
collectivités que nous travaillons c'est
dans l'intérêt des français c'est dans
l'intérêt de la capacité de répondre à
leurs besoins
est-ce qu'on n'a pas constaté au cours
de cette crise sanitaire que les
collectivités étaient plus rapides plus
agile plus réactives pour apporter des
solutions besoin bien tirerons les
enseignements de cette crise et
équilibrons les pouvoirs dans notre pays
en permettant aux collectivités de faire
ce que l'état n'a pas su faire ou ne
sait pas faire d'autres questions non
j'aurais simplement peut-être en
conclusion parce que je vous garantis
qu'on est déterminé et dans notre
diversité c'est à dire toutes les
propositions way éric kerrouche ici il a
fait deux propositions de résolutions je
vois le président retailleau le
président marseille qui est ici présent
jma d'autres groupes qui sont ici
représentés mais les propositions de loi
sont pas au pas vocation à être sur une
étagère
elles ont vocation à instituer aussi une
méthode j'évoquais tout à l'heure et il
ya eu une contribution très très
intéressante de notre collègue de la
délégation août robert comme nous avons
contribution de nos collègues des
finances et d'un ami l'eau pour la
commission des affaires sociales est qui
amen dans des propositions mais qui va
sans doute amené à a+ que cela parce
qu'il ya une consultation absolument
incroyable de l'ensemble des exécutifs
de ces territoires
je pourrais peut-être en conclusion
donner la parole à la fois françoise
gatel et mathieu darnaud mais ils
parleront d'une seule voix sur la
méthode illustrative comment en juin
on vote une proposition de loi qui va en
fait changer la nature et la profondeur
d'engagement et proximité les jours et
ce sera mon mot de conclusion puisque je
laisserai à françoise gatel c'était son
rôle de sage pendant nos réunions ne
soigne conclure je voudrais d'abord
remercier le travail qui a été fait pour
mercier des présents nombreux et vous
dire que ce travail vient de loin je
vous rassure on s'y retrouvera entre
territoires unis l'exécutif et d'autres
associations mais si ça traduit une
vitalité
je dis que si on n'a pas une nouvelle
génération de décentralisation il
manquera une des matrices essentiel si
nous voulons redresser ce pays lui
redonner confiance et sortir de la crise
morale dans lequel nous sommes
c'est pas les élus par nos élus c'est
d'abord une question de citoyens par
rapport au territoire par rapport à la
proximité est en essai en essayant de ne
pas opposer les uns aux autres et
citoyens de l'espace rural comme les
citoyens qui habitent les métropoles ils
sont des compatriotes et on doit
apporter des réponses et c'est autour de
cela mais je lui cède la parole à la
fois française gatel et mathieu darnaud
qui parle d'une voix mais c'est souvent
le cas d'anne merci monsieur le
président ruiz au travers de mon propos
j'associe par le jet ceci mathieu
darnaud dans mon propos je vous remercie
président bonjour à tous alors je
voudrais à la fois alors être la sage de
l'assemblée c'est un exercice qui me
paraît fort difficile parce que nous
avons là trois éminents ça plus
sérieusement je voudrais dire que nous
ne sommes pas dans la compétition ou la
provocation
et c'est pas la surenchère qui aura le
plus de propositions et qui aura le
meilleur je dirais juste que le
foisonnement des propositions le
foisonnement des réflexions prouve une
chose pour ceux qui en doutaient c'est
qu'il y a nécessité de faire bouger et
de réfléchir à l'architecturé de notre
pays
aujourd'hui chacun le dit on le répète
mais c'est une évidence nous sommes dans
un pays qui est fatigué qui est
fracturée qui est plein de courbatures
les élus sont épuisés par des réformes
successives qui n'ont pas prouvé leur
efficience et nos concitoyens ne sont
pas dans l'harmonie la plus totale et
l'objectif qui est le nôtre c'est ce
qu'a rappelé le président c'est de faire
qu'il y ait une action publique qui soit
efficace que les élus puissent assumer
les compétences qui sont les leurs et
que nos concitoyens
là où il habite quel que soit leur âge
leur profession retrouve aussi les
valeurs de la république c'est
simplement ça l'enjeu alors certains ont
posé la question de la différenciation
s'est fracturé l'égalité alors moi
j'aime beaucoup cette question parce
qu'effectivement on peut dire que si on
accumule des exceptions deux territoires
ont créé des compétitions un peu
délicate entre les deux et toi moi je ne
le crois pas je crois bien au contraire
que l'uniformité n'est pas l'égalité
mais que l'uniformité des serres
l'égalité ce n'est pas en ayant des
structures absolument identique du nord
au sud et de l'est à l'ouest qu'on va
servir nos concitoyens est la preuve
elle est là je regarde mon collègue
michel magras qui nous a beaucoup parlé
des territoires ultra marins et de leurs
spécificités
nulle en france ne viendrait nier la
nécessité d'adapter la loi aux
spécificités des territoires ultramarins
pour que tous les habitants des
territoires ultramarins soient égaux à
tous les français en droit et en liberté
la création de la collectivité
européenne d'alsace est-ce qu'elle a
fracturé la république je ne crois pas
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y à une
urgence à agir parce que ce pays
il doit être remis sur pied nous avons
des défis socio sanitaire écologique à
relever il faut que chacun joue sa place
et que l'état surtout se contente avec
excellence de faire ce qu'il doit faire
c'est à dire exercer ses missions
régaliennes et surtout assurer l'équité
en permettant que les territoires soient
aidés et soit facilitée on sort d'une
décennie d'essorage financiers dans les
collectivités de contraintes normatives
qui nous ont paralysé et aujourd'hui on
voit apparaître une nouvelle génération
d'élus assez remarquables qui ont
beaucoup d'idées qui sont des inventeurs
de possibles laissons-les faire faisons
leur confiance
accompagnant l'est le pays se portera
mieux et je pense qu'on retrouvera aussi
dans ce pays un peu plus de concorde et
de cohésion sociale et je crois que
c'est un défi que nous devons partager
et c'est le sens de notre contribution
majeure d'app l'eau
mahmoud thiam
[Musique]
voilà pour cette conférence de presse
que vous avez pu suivre en intégralité
et en direct sur public sénat voilà
c'est 50 propositions pour le plein
exercice des libertés locales sont
présentés par le sénat comme une réponse
à la crise démocratique notamment va
tout de suite rejoindre alexandre
poussard qui nous attend la présidence
du sénat alexandre qu'est ce que vous
vous retenez est bien de cette
conférence de presse et bientôt on peut
dire que les président larcher et bae
bockel ont défendu un véritable acte de
décentralisation et parmi les
propositions positives propositions
fortes faites par les sénateurs il y à
la question de l'argent avec la règle
qui décident paix qui doit être selon
inscrite dans la constitution
concrètement cela veut dire que si on
donne des compétences aux collectivités
eh bien l'état doit associer des moyens
à ces nouvelles compétences les
sénateurs également un moratoire sur la
réforme des finances locales qui doit
compenser la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation qui a fragilisé l'autonomie
financière des collectivités
et puis le sénat souhaite renforcer les
compétences de ces collectivités
territoriales d'abord la commune pour
qu'elles ne deviennent pas je cite une
coquille vide pour que le département
pilote un vrai bloc de compétences
sociales pour que la région pilote
davantage la politique économique et la
politique en faveur de l'emploi
toutes ces mesures elles vont se
traduire par des textes de loi des
textes constitutionnels organique et
ordinaire qui seront proposés par les
sénateurs durant ce mois de juillet
merci beaucoup à alexandre pons
décryptage
et bien nos invités sont toujours là sur
ce plateau benjamin morel vous que
retenez-vous est bien de cette
conférence de presse qui a commencé
d'abord est bien aussi sur les
municipales abstention et la crise
démocratique
oui il ya en effet une volonté de
pallier la crise démocratique après on
est tout de même face à un éléments d'aq
roche face à une conjoncture qui fait
que en effet aujourd'hui quand on a des
enquêtes d'opinion on avait fait
notamment une pour la répu pour la revue
politique et parlementaire qui montrait
que les français ne comprenait pas
réellement le sens de la
décentralisation aujourd'hui et qu'une
réflexion sur à quoi ça sert à des
centrales
a sion quelles sont les compétences
assignataire niveaux de collectivités et
probablement une nécessité près comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est pas non
plus une priorité pour les français
ce qu'on peut retenir de cette
conférence c'est qu'en effet il y a des
propositions qui sont mises en avant à
presque toutes ces propositions
prospéreront c'est plus compliqué qu'on
voit très bien qu'il ya beaucoup
notamment de propositions
constitutionnelles
on évoquait tout à l'heure le calendrier
ça apparaît relativement compliqué on a
vu que la loi organique relative à la
différenciation proposé par le
gouvernement avaient déjà été soumis au
conseil d'état
donc on voit que le gouvernement a tout
de même un calendrier en tête donc pour
toutes ces raisons là ya tout de même
des propositions des avancées notamment
sur les compétences qui pourraient être
déléguée sur un certain nombre
d'éléments permettant de donner plus de
liberté et ya des casus belli qui reste
là notamment sur les finances locales
je vais vous faire réagir mais tout de
suite on va rejoindre alexandre à la
présidence du sénat car vous êtes avec
le président de la commission des lois
le sénateur philippe bas et oui philippe
à une question sur les compétences de
ces collectivités locales dans votre
projet de décentralisation
quelle collectivité doit voir quelles
compétences dans les leçons tirées de
cette crise sanitaire
c'est un des points de nos propositions
nous voulons que là où l'état n'a pas
réussi à être efficace il délègue la
compétence collectivités territoriales
donc la santé
pardon sur la santé notamment sur la
santé sur l'emploi sur l'enseignement
supérieur pour les régions sur le social
avec les établissements et services pour
personnes âgées pour personnes
handicapées mais aussi pour l'enfance et
la médecine scolaire pour les
départements et donc vous voyez que
l'idée au fond c'est un meilleur service
pour nos concitoyens que on part de cet
espoir raisonné que la collectivité
parce qu'elle est proche des gens elle
va pouvoir si on lui en donne les moyens
si ces liberté d'initiative sont
reconnus apporter un meilleur service
dans tous ces domaines regarder la
politique de l'emploi est ce qu'au cours
des dernières décennies
le fait d'avoir centraliser la politique
de l'emploi comme on l'a fait a été
efficace pour l'emploi et il suffit de
regarder les chiffres
la réponse est non et donc on espère
surtout au moment où se développe une
crise économique et sociale que nous
pourrons parvenir par le renforcement
des libertés locales à rendre plus
efficaces les services et les
équipements pour nos concitoyens
est ce que vous pensez qu emmanuel
macron va vraiment réaliser un véritable
acte de décentralisation est ce que vous
y croyez
je l'espère ça n'est pas ce qu'il a fait
jusqu'à présent mais je pense que les
secousses
qu'il a subies pendant la première
partie de son quinquennat
l'eau sans doute et éclairé sur une
meilleure compréhension de ce que sont
les énergies locales de ce que sont les
initiatives locales de ce que sont les
forces vives du pays
au fond ce n'est pas parce que on est à
la tête de l'état qu'on est tout
puissant parce que l'état lui même a ses
limites quand même mais nous sommes des
rénovateurs de l'état aussi nous voulons
que l'état puisse s'engager auprès des
élus alors que souvent les choses
remontent à paris la coopération entre
l'état et les élus locaux écrit merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup alexandre géraldine
chabrier on voit il espère d'emmanuel
macro un nouvel acte de décentralisation
mais pour l'instant les sénateurs n'y
crois pas ils disent chiche
oui alors bon on n'a pas de moyens de
déterminer ce qui se fera effectivement
je crois sincèrement que depuis
plusieurs mois on sent que les choses
vont se faire simplement il va falloir
le faire intelligemment on a des textes
la révision constitutionnelle je crois
qu'il faut oublier on peut pas l'on peut
pas l'imaginer dans un délai aussi court
il va falloir travailler beaucoup et que
les lois organiques tout ce qu'on peut
faire avec la révision constitutionnelle
il suffit de modifier la loi organique
je pense à l'autonomie financière le
tome i financière le principe
constitutionnel de le tenue financière
était bien parti le loi organique là
complètement anéanti il va falloir
changer tout peut être fait par le
président macron en travaillant sur les
services administratifs le principal
obstacle à la décentralisation c'est les
services des ministères
parce que rentrer dans le détail de la
norme parce que eux ont des défiance à
l'égard des collectivités avant de faire
des textes qu'ils voient chacun chaque
ministre leur leurs responsables
administratifs et qu'il voit de cette
façon comment ils peuvent évoluer
on va tout de suite rejoindre alexandre
plus tard car alexandre vous êtes
maintenant avec le président du sénat
gérard larcher
monsieur le président vous allez
rencontrer emmanuel macron cet après
midi le président de la république qui a
l'air ouvert pour je cite libérer les
énergies des acteurs de terreur voulu
dit chiche
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est la fin
d'un président de la république
jupitérien
je ne sais pas d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
si les jubilés rien ce que je crois
qu'il faut que nous réfléchissions
ensemble à inverser la verticalité ce
pays tout ne peut pas procéder du
pouvoir central
autant le pouvoir central doit être très
impliqué dans les questions régaliennes
regardez aujourd'hui les interrogations
sur la justice le malaise de la police
et de la gendarmerie
l'importance des relations
internationales autant si nous voulons
conduire la relance retrouver la
confiance faire face à un automne qui
risque d'être socialement extrêmement
difficile il faut qu'on le fasse avec
les collectivités territoriales savez
premier vainqueur de dimanche
malheureusement ça a était l'abstention
mais en mutant les français et le monde
sondage après sondage font confiance en
leurs élus locaux particulièrement leur
mère je crois qu'il faut qu'on saisit
cette chanson semble et l'unité
nationale pourrait se faire sur cette
nouvelle génération de la
décentralisation alors ces propositions
vont se traduire par trois textes de loi
et notamment une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle
est-ce que vous pensez que pour réussir
cette décentralisation avec le
gouvernement il faut séparer la révision
constitutionnelle territoriale et
l'autre bloc de la révision
constitutionnelle mission des lois nous
ce qu'il déposerait des textes en même
temps parce qu'il ya une logique relève
de la constitution par exemple il l'a
dit la compétence générale
le principe qui décident paix et ensuite
la décliner par des lois ordinaires on
aura besoin de ce substrat une des
préoccupations qui a marqué tous les
groupes politiques ici c'est qu'au fond
ne soit pas dans la situation issue 2003
une volonté décentralisation du
président de la république jacques
chirac
vingt ans après la volonté de du
président mitterrand
et on a vu un état une administration et
haute administration en fait reprendre
d'une main tout ce qui avait été donné
de l'autre et finalement cette évolution
constitutionnelle elle n'a pas été
traduit dans les faits jamais et ça n'a
pas commencé au printemps 2017
jamais la recentralisation n'a été plus
forte qu'au cours de ces dix dernières
années au qu'il faut l'inscrire dans la
constitution
dernière question monsieur le président
le président de la république est plutôt
favorable à un report des élections
régionales et départementales notamment
pour est bien orchestré la relance
économique et à cette réforme de
l'organisation de l'état
vous êtes favorable également non je
suis pour respecter le calendrier mais
je trouve que tout est dans la réponse
du premier ministre fait devant nos
collègues députés mardi
c'est à dire il faut qu'il ya un
consensus il a dit il faut qu'il ya un
motif d'intérêt général majeur il faut
peut bien sûr passer par la loi et sous
le contrôle du conseil constitutionnel
je crois que tout est dit ça fait
beaucoup rire cet acte on nous parle de
référendum
alors est-ce qu'une campagne
référendaire ne perturbera pas autant
qu'une campagne régionale et
départementale allez faut qu'on se dise
les choses
je pense qu'en démocratie elle a besoin
de stabilité
elle a besoin pour retrouver la
confiance et le respect du calendrier
sauf motif majeur me semble est une
attitude qui peut contribuer à ces deux
confié donc envoyé un petit peu de
tambouille électorale je parle pas du
mot de tambouille je pense qu'il faut
qu'on joue l'intérêt du pays et savez je
reçois ma permanence
jamais autant de jeunes qui sont à la
recherche d'un emploi d'un stage une
formation par alternance
c'est à dire aux français qu'il faut
répondre et c'est pas une affaire de
cuisine et est français on les consulte
il vote où ils votent pas retrouvant la
confiance et faisant confiance en la
démocratie qu'on allait servir l'intérêt
des français avant tous merci beaucoup
monsieur le président d'avoir répondu à
mes questions
merci alexandre pour cette nouvelle
réaction
la politique elle n'est pas loin dans
cette conférence sont à voir les
sénatoriales là on parle des régionales
jean baptiste forêt oui tout à fait
parce que le président de la république
voudrait selon un certain nombre
d'années discrétion reporter les
départementales et régionales afin 2022
c'est à dire à la presse présidentielle
c'est vrai qu'on attaque très très mal
cette voie là que d'externalisation
c'est à dire quand on démarre de la
cuisine
enfin on arrive quand même rarement très
très très très loin au final ça ça me
fait penser aussi à ce qu'avait pu faire
nicolas sarkozy
enfin il ya du nicolas sarkozy
emmanuelle macron dans ce tempérament
parfois explosif et ça s'était mal ça
s'était mal terminée en particulier ici
même au sénat il avait perdu les
élections à la à la haute assemblée
en 2011 je ne pense pas que c'est de
cette façon là qui pourra reconquérir le
conquérir même le coeur des élus locaux
mais on sent qu effectivement il ya de
la tension entre l'exécutif et les
sénateurs d'ailleurs et bien gérard
larcher a commencé son allocution
avec une attaque n'attaque au délitement
de l'état écouter crise après crise les
français constatent aussi le délitement
de l'état incapable de se recentrer sur
ses missions régaliennes un état qui
veut s'occuper de tout régler tout mais
à l'état au fonds
affaibli et qui multiplie les freins
initiatives des collectivités
territoriales et qui persiste à vouloir
imposer des règles uniformes
d'organisation qui au fond concrètement
éloigne des décisions des citoyens
c'est assez offensif benjamin morel oui
mais gérard larcher nous a habitués aux
conférences de presse des bleus rey à
fleuret moucheté contre emmanuel macron
souvient notamment des voeux etc
donc oui c'est un peu offensif après on
est dans la continuité d'une séquence
politique qui a été celle du confinement
où on a vu les élus locaux notamment les
élus locaux lr attaqué bille en tête
l'état et le gouvernement ce que
d'ailleurs assez peu apprécié emmanuel
macron qui a senti peut-être un peu
d'opportunisme politique
donc après en effet on est dans une
période de tension aujourd'hui entre le
sénat et le président de la république
qui est peut-être moins exacerbée qui a
quelques temps mais qui est tout de même
demeure profondément ancrées et qui
renvoie également à ce que vous évoquez
concernant les élections régionales
là on a une vraie vraie question qui va
se poser ce corps portait des élections
régionales en 2022 celle est reportée
dans la roue de la présidentielle faut
bien comprendre que du coup celui qui
emporte les présidentielles
potentiellement importe législatives
mais également les régionales et
départementales
donc on a des présidents de région qui a
raison peuvent se sentir menacés pour
leur réélection
dans une telle manoeuvre par ailleurs ea
comme le disait bien gérard larcher on
voit mal pourquoi parce qu'il ya une
crise économique et parce qu'on n'a pas
fait à temps une loi qu'on voulait faire
plus tôt eh bien on devrait reporter
tout l'ensemble des élections donc on
voit très bien que le parti socialiste a
voté une résolution contre que les
républicains également ils sont
prononcés contre ce report est que les
présidents de région dans leur grande
majorité sont contre arriver à faire un
consensus là dessus c'est compliqué
c'est emmanuel macron le veut vraiment
il va à la guerre contre le sénat et
contre les collectivités
c'est dans ce contexte politique
électorat qui font entendre un certain
nombre de phrases ont pu prononcer tout
à l'heure et bien notamment philippe bas
qui a dit la centralisation c'est
l'étouffoir des initiatives l'asphyxient
des libertés locales lorsque jean marie
bockel a parlé aussi de l'insidieuse
dynamique centralise hartley
centralisatrice pardon
et en disant encore une fois le
gouvernement en est seulement aux effets
d'annoncé avec sa loi 3 d écouter de
toute façon tous ces termes là on les
entend depuis 25 ans donc oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est de plus en plus vrai je
crois pas qu'on en soit causé fed
annonce avec la loi 3d même si c'est
vrai qu'elle a eu du mal à sortir 1 on
l'a attendu on n'entendait plus d
informations sur la déconcentration qui
est ceci étant dit très utile que sur la
décentralisation et moi je crois
vraiment je ne sais pas je suis
peut-être excessivement optimiste mais
je pense vraiment que la
décentralisation est en train de devenir
un bien commun des tensions politiques
oui puisqu'il y a des échéances
politiques mais gauche comme droite est
absolument convaincu qu'il faut évoluer
et je pense sincèrement qu'il va se
passer quelque chose dans les années qui
viennent
le l'obstacle principal il sera toujours
celui que j'ai énoncé tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que si on veut évoluer faut
pas modifier les textes il faut changer
la culture la culture administrative
il faut ne plus avoir peur de la fin de
l'égalité j'entendais ce journaliste
expliquant que la différenciation
c'était la fin d'égalité mais si son
enfant passe un examen qu'il est aveugle
il va trouver que c'est la fin de
l'égalité si on lui donne un tiers temps
supplémentaire c'est pas ça la
différenciation s'éprendre qu'on
recompte des différences de situation
pour avancer donc quand on aura mis à
fin à toutes ces vieilles lunes de la
fin de l'égalité de la fin de l'unité de
l'état
on avancera en effet je crois qu'on
avance dans ce sur ce chemin oui on
avance en tout cas le sénat a parlé tout
à l'heure et bien de nouvelles
compétences de nouvelles attributions
aux collectivités en écoutant nous
voulons donner aux collectivités la
pleine et entière responsabilité de
compétences qu elles nous paraissent
pouvoir mieux exercer que l'état parce
qu'elles sont en proximité parce que
leur exercice pourra être plus souple et
plus réactif
par exemple confié de nouvelles
compétences l'emploi et la santé
notamment le champ médico social mais
aussi des compétences pour mener la
transition
écologique j'ai fait mienne la formule
que me donnait le président de
l'association des maires du nord l'été
dernier l'écologie punitive venu d'en
haut divise l'écologie locale rassemble
mémoire aussi de ce qui s'était passé
avec la crise
des gilets jaunes crise délit gilet
jaune et vague verte des municipales
important pour gérard larcher aussi de
rappeler bien que l'écologie elle est
déjà présente au niveau local
oui alors qu'elle est non seulement
présente au niveau local mais qu'on voit
même que du point de vue des français il
ya un échelon local pour les questions
écologiques qui apparaît extrêmement
important après il faut également alors
on s'inscrit peut-être un petit peu en
faux là dessus il faut également faire
un
restez attentifs à l'égalité notamment
sur ces questions écologiques
on voit qu'en effet il ya des risques et
bien d'avoir des politiques à géométrie
variable qui peuvent être très
problématique
donc il ya un rapport du fmi 2014 qui
est assez intéressant c'est à dire qu'on
peut avoir éventuellement un des
politiques divers sur l'ensemble du
territoire mais à condition d'avoir un
état qui créait l'égalité ce que
d'ailleurs on dit les sénateurs sinon
vous créez comme en espagne des
collectivités prédatrice par ailleurs
sur la question de la différenciation
faut quand même faire un petit peu
attention on voit très clairement que ce
qui a été produit à travers des
collectivités à statut particulier
c est jean marie bockel l'a bien évoqué
comme étant en danger et bien une
potentielle montée du régionalisme on a
vu comment la collectivité unique de
corse a dynamisé le régionalisme en
corse
on voit aujourd'hui dans les enquêtes
d'opinion notamment celles pour l'ifop
que la collectivité européenne d'alsace
est en train de créer une dynamisation
du norrland on a des études macro
statistique fait par mme astié shekels
là-dessus qui montre que quand vous
singulariser vous créez une donne une
dynamique d'émiettement de l'état jean
baptiste forêt oui je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que dit benjamin morale
sur la différenciation emmanuel macron
promeut quand même une conception assez
assez managériale en fait de l'action
publique c'est une sorte de
décentralisation 2.0 sans fin on voit
pas le bout du bout de cette de cette
différenciation là on voit un clivage
comme un apparaître entre emmanuel
macron qu'ils quitteraient annonce sur
ces sujets là et le sénat qui est
beaucoup plus réservé et peut-être même
edouard philippe lui-même
faut quand même pas oublier qu edouard
philippe et un conseiller d'état donc la
différenciation je suis pas certain que
ce soit ni un concept extrêmement
tendance du côté du conseil d'état même
si même si sa position a évolué mais si
vous sentir quand même sa tradition
jacobine et il a complètement ils
faisaient de ces dernières décennies
ça mérite quand même confirmation c'est
lui la différenciation c'est parce qu'on
croit la différenciation le conseil
constitutionnel la pic depuis très
longtemps le conseil d'état l'a rendu
possible ces derniers mois il faut pas
avoir peur de la prise en compte des
différences de situations y aura
toujours un état parce qu'on sera
toujours dans un état unitaire qui au
qui adoptera une loi unique un cadre
général et c'est à l'intérieur de ce
cadre qu on veut juste
donner un petit peu de marge de
manoeuvre pour pouvoir avoir des
politiques plus efficaces parce que
calibré à leurs destinataires et à leur
territoire et c'est ce que veut faire
cette nouvelle réforme je crois le sénat
comme le président mac ou les libertés
locales sont constitutifs d'une
république une et indivisible attend
pions également entendre ce matin
merci beaucoup à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette ambition très bonne
journée sur les chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]